Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Also ich gebe mir auf jeden Fall Mühe, dass die Integrität und Vertraulichkeit meiner informationstechnischen Systeme gewährleistet ist.
Integer unvertraulich, so kennt ihr uns Lokbuchnetzpolitik in seiner einhundertneunundsiebzigsten Inkarnation frisch aus der Metaebene in eure Hörgänge gespült. Ähm,
Ja und heute machen wir mal wieder das, was wir immer ein Spezial nennen. Stimmt's?
Ja, heute machen wir ein Spezial.
Spezial und wie sich das für so ein Spezial gehört haben wir dann auch speziellen Gast.
Ich will jetzt nicht das Wort Spezialexperte hören.
Nein, nein, Spezialexpertin.
Versteh.
Ganz genau. Ja, Konstanze, Konstanze kurz, herzlich willkommen.
Hallo, ich freue mich. Ich war ja schon mal hier.
Genau. Äh der geneigte Hörer äh ahnt schon worum es geht.
Wir haben gerade gesagt, wir haben nur Hörerinnen.
Äh ja, sorry, jetzt ist alles alles durch. Die geneigte Hörerin ahnt schon, worum es geht.
Es geht um die Staatstrojanerin.
Heute machen wir das generische Filminum zur Startsaison. Genau.
Der Konstanze niemals beigebrach.
Nein, nein, bestimmt nicht. Das scheitert auch so ein bisschen. Äh lassen wir den Sport auch wieder. Was ist passiert? Es gab ein Urteil vom Bundesverfassungsgericht und äh ja äh bisher ein Dauergast, ne.
Na ja tatsächlich war ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal da, aber.
Wie viele Male warst du jetzt eigentlich schon da? Also ich weiß es.
Also in eigenem Auftrag sozusagen.
Einmal Wahlcomputer, etwa einmal der der Hackerparagraph aber da fand keine Anhörung statt, war nur schriftlich, dann war die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, dann war die Antiterrordatei und jetzt das BKA-Gesetz.
Gibt's eine Schnittchen, wenn man da so.
Nee, nee. Man man darf da nicht mal den internen Kaffeeautomat benutzen, der ist nur für Mitarbeiter. Man muss da immer Kaffee mitbringen.
Wie du, man darf da Kaffee mit reinbringen.
Habe ich ja gestern Morgen.
Aber keine Muttermilch in Flughafen oder was.
Äh ich habe nie versucht Mutter mich im Flughafen mitzunehmen. Ich kenne nur die Geschichten aus dem In.
Das heißt, da sitzen dann alle so mit ihren Thermoskannen und Plastikbechern. Das ist schönes Bild.
Nee, aber also wenn die langen Anhörungen sind, die sind dann immer so fünf, sechs Stunden, dann dann machen die auch lange Pausen, dann geht man halt Mittagessen und so und dann holt man sich,
trotzdem bin ich jetzt öfter da, weil also eine gewisse Ehrfurcht äh hat man schon immer noch und die haben auch mal diese Rituale geschafft, dann mal erzählt und es ist nicht so, dass ich alltäglich finde. Und ich war auch ein bisschen so morgens, oh, ich werde durchaus nervös. Man weiß ja nicht, was steht im Urteil?
Und deswegen man redet ja, man man kennt ja all die Leute, die waren ja in der Anhörung auch da, ist schon immer ein bisschen man merkt auch, dass alles so ein bisschen flatterig sind morgens.
Hat auch gesehen, dass der Gerd Baum im Flatterich war. Noch abends in der Tagesschau bei der im Nachtmagazin war das so, aber wir haben das in den Linksester das war die.
Ein Stück, also nach dem Urteil natürlich wir sind noch ein Stück zusammen zurückgefahren im Zug und haben natürlich auch geredet und dann also da geht's dann schon im Wesentlichen darum, ja man hat so dicke Deutsche und dann redet man natürlich auch dadrüber, wie man dann interpretiert und so. Also ist schon, man,
ja also das ist spannend
Aber gleichzeitig also man weiß ja vorher, dass man, man kriegt ja nie sonst totales Urteil, ja? Ist nie was komplett verboten oder so, sondern man kriegt ja immer so ein Ja, aber.
Man kriegt so ein Rätsel, wie wie früher beim Orakel von Delfi, du fragst uns was und es antwortet in einem R.
Nee, nee, eigentlich solltet ja immer eine gewisse Klärung bringen. Also insofern so werden wir mit dem Orakel jetzt nicht unterschreiben, aber es ist natürlich nie
Bausch und Bogen wird alles verworfen, sondern man kriegt immer einige das okay, Mathe kann man machen. Also ich bin nie zufrieden,
Natürlich nicht.
Deswegen fährst du auch immer wieder hin.
Naja, äh also ich bin ja kein Gerüst, äh klar, also mir ging's ja da auch um diese technischen Dinge. Also zu sagen einfach äh ja zur Aufklärung das Gericht beitragen, ist ja auch der Grund, warum die Sachverständige holen.
Genau, du warst also das als Sachverständige da mit einer Meinung, die du da vertreten hast, Beschwerde.
Und wir haben eine Stellungnahme abgegeben auch schriftlich.
Alleine, also ich meine, hat.
Na vorgetragen habe ich es alleine, aber geschrieben, nicht alleine.
Geschrieben, kann man, glaube ich, auch sagen, ne? Äh Konstanze kurz, Frank Rieger, Dirk Engling, Thorsten Schröder haben diese Stellungnahme geschrieben, von der wir jetzt später noch reden wollen, aber wir haben uns ja überlegt, wir wollen vielleicht
Dieses Urteil mal in den geschichtlichen Kontext setzen, denn diese Geschichte,
BKA-Gesetz oder in diesem Fall insbesondere Staatstrojaner beschäftigt ja äh die Bundesrepublik äh das Bundesverfassungsgericht und äh den Chaos-Computerclub ja schon seit einiger Zeit, seit acht Jahren.
Oh, eigentlich sogar noch länger. Ja, ja. Genau.
Und es ging, die Geschichte geht los zweitausendacht mit dem,
ersten in der Hinsicht relevanten Urteil vom Bund des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, in dem äh wir ein äh neues Grundrecht gewonnen haben,
war da, was du da auch schon als Sachverständige oder nur als interessierte Beobachterin.
Ja, da war der CTC auch als Sachverstand technischer Sachverständiger, aber vorgetragen hat der Andreas Bug. Da lag auch ein
also auch in der Anhörung damals äh zweitausendsieben war net ein großer Fokus auf der Technik. Da wollten die Rechte vor allen Dingen verstehen, was was machen denn teuer? Da wo sind die ganzen technisch etwas sehr spannend auch. Etwa ein hohes Niveau auch der der Diskussionen da auch für viele Stunden äh und anders als beim BKA-Gesetz jetzt war
ja Dinge doch so gut wie nur um diesen Trojaner. Das war ein Landesgesetz damals in nordrhein-westfälischer Verfassungsschutz hat diese Erlaubnis bekommen.
war. War auch super interessant.
Dass das niveautechnisch hoch war, kann ich mir bei Andreas Book als Sachverständigen auch nicht anders vorstellen, aber das Gericht hat,
hast du mir glaube ich schon öfter so gesagt, das Gericht ist da sehr interessiert,
Solchen komplizierteren oder nicht alltäglich komplexen Ausführungen äh durchaus mal auch zu folgen. Äh oder.
Man merkt's auch an den, also man merkt das natürlich an den Rückfragen, da also das ist ja nicht zur Faschine, da steht man da nicht und trägt da nur ein Statement vor, sondern hat auch dialogische Komponenten. Man es gibt da Nachfragen und so. Man,
Also ist heute ein bisschen anders, muss ich sagen, also als wir die ersten Male da waren, war dann ein bisschen anders strukturiert, hängt auch da mal zusammen, wer,
den Sonat führt und die Verhandlungen, also jeder hat da so ein bisschen seine Art und damals war der noch der Pap hier, der ehemalige Präsident, der hatte sehr, sehr strukturiert. Der hat sich da auch nicht viel reinreden lassen. Heute das letzte Mal liegt der im Wald durchaus lockerer,
Das heißt, man konnte sich auch mal melden, wenn man was sagen wollte, das hat der Papier äh so nicht zugelassen. Der hatte zuerst äh stark strukturiert.
Wo sind wir denn, ehrlich? Ich meine, das Bundesverfassung, du kannst ja nicht einfach melden, so irgendwie vom Jahrmark.
Es heute äh aus meiner Sicht ist es deutlich offener. Ich finde auch nicht, dass es der Qualität äh besonders tuchträglich ist. Das ist natürlich jetzt schon mal so, dass der Vertreter etwa der Bundesregierung den Mats Zwischenruf und gerne was sagen will und so äh,
jetzt ist es auch nicht mehr so, dass vorher total klar ist, wenn man spricht,
gab Safra schon nee, die kamen gar nicht zu Wort. Weil sie schon hinten Themen oder so nicht geschafft haben. Das ist bei Papiersohn nicht gewesen. Aber ich glaube, ähm ich habe ja nur einen anderen Salat auch schon mal erlebt,
also weil der erste Senat gibt ja noch einen zweiten hat jeder der diese Behandlung führt aus so seiner Art.
Wenn's der Wahrheitsfindung dient.
Also ganz klar ist die Lesenheit, die Stellungnahmen auch. Und hier war das auch deutlich komplexer, BKA-Gesetz hat ganz viele Dinge, die die Beschwerdeführer
bemängelt haben und damals bei dem bei dem alten Staatsröhrner Urteil gingen eben wirklich sehr fokussiert um diesen Treueanaer und diesmal waren natürlich sehr viele andere Sachen die Wohnraumüberwachung
akustisch und optisch. Der geht auch um Spitze, da ging es um Datenaustausch,
zwischen Behörden und auch ins Ausland. Natürlich ging's auch um die verschiedenen Trojaner, aber da war eben viel, viel mehr drin und auch teilweise sehr defizielle, juristische Fragen.
Vielleicht ähm bleiben wir trotzdem nochmal kurz bei der Geschichte, also zweitausendacht an äh zweitausendsieben Anhörung Andreas Burg, Urteil war zweitausendacht, glaube ich.
Mhm. Siebenundzwanzigster Februar.
Und da wurde verhandelt ein nordrhein-westfälischer Staatstrojaner oder die.
Das Landesverfassungsschutzamt hat bekommen, aber es war sehr bemerkenswert, dass dort äh ganz viele Bundesbehörden äh anrück,
der ein Landesgesetz war. Also das heißt äh die Richter es war schon klar, dass die da auch ein bisschen Gesetze schreiben, obwohl sie dann immer von sich weisen. Weil die Bundesbehörden angehört wurden, BKA, obwohl sie ja mit denen formal gar nichts zu tun hatte.
Natürlich kommt die Bundesregierung, wenn ihr Testballon auf einmal bis nach Karlsruhe geflogen ist, ne.
Nicht so,
Selbstverständlich der Primär interpret der Verfassung ist unser Gesetzgeber und dass sie, dass wir uns daran gewöhnt haben, dass sie sozusagen aus den Urteilen kopieren, halte ich nicht für einen Normalzustand,
und etwa so der erste Fall damals, wo plötzlich er wurde und diese Ness äh Gesetz ging und die öffentliche Diskussion um den Staatstrainer schon so war. Und damit einmal zu seinen ganzen Bundesämtern ankamen und so
Also es war klar, dass die sich in gewisser Weise Gesetz BKA gesetzt haben, schreiben lassen und das haben sie faktisch gemacht, weil kurz danach zweitausendneun,
haben sie wirklich auch Teile übernommen, insbesondere was den Trojaner betrifft, richtig aus dem Urteil kopiert.
Denn zweitausendacht, wir haben das neue Grundrecht gewonnen, das Grundrecht auf Gewährleistung der Integrität und Vertraulichkeit informationstechnischer Systeme,
aufgeschrieben, bin ich ganz ehrlich, ich hab's. Ich zitiere das immer falsch. Ähm, da gibt's aber auch ein Chaosradio zu, Chaosradio hundert zweiunddreißig mit dem Titel Computerverwanzung,
Ähm was war denn, welcher welcher welche Meinung hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht, denn damals vertreten zweitausendacht.
Ne, das eine ist, man kann ja nicht Grundrecht auch mal wörtlich nehmen. Also Grundrecht, der Staat hat zu gewährleisten, dass Informationstechnisches Thema und deren Vertraulichkeit und Intimität eben
gewährleistet werden, also man muss man muss ja diese Gewährleistung als eine staatliche Aufgabe sehen. Hm in der Sache aber,
war da auch schon viel von dem sogenannten Kernbereichschutz die Rede und der Kernbereich privater Lebensgescheitung, wie die Juristen sagen, ist eben nicht höchstpersönlich ja. Es ist nicht die Privatsphäre eines Menschen, sondern eben,
eher die Intimsphäre. Also Dinge, die man nur mit sehr engen Vertrauten austauscht.
aber zweitausendacht, er war sicherlich die Debatte nicht dieselbe wie heute, wo irgendwie Leute, weiß ich nicht, ihren äh ihre Sexvideos
Mobiltelefon haben und überhaupt jeder fünf Computer hat, aber trotzdem war schon klar, dass auf informationstechnischen Geräten aller Art
auch eben höchstpersönliche das. Also diese Debatte um den Kernbereich der war schon damals drin.
Ist der ist diese Debatte da erst äh entstanden. Ich erinnere mich immer an so, weiß ich nicht, Filme wie Casino, wo oder überhaupt dieses
also Casino, da gibt's irgendwie diese Szenen, wo die, wo die S ihre, ihre Frauen telefonieren lassen und dann die Abhörenden, Beamten, dann das Tonbandgerät ausschalten und das Abhören abbrechen und dann,
telefonieren die Gangster miteinander, weil's irgendwie.
Nahe die Kernbereichsdebatte kommt eigentlich aus einer anderen großen großen deutschen politischen Diskussion, nämlich die um den großen Rauschangriff,
in deren Folge ja auch damals äh Sabine Luthholzer Schnarrenberger zurücktritt, nämlich die Frage nach Wanzen im Schlafzimmer. Da ist dieses ganze Konzept sozusagen mal dargelegt worden, wie man
Wenn man in Wohnräumen abhören kann, dafür sorgt, dass der sogenannte absolute geschützte Bereich der privaten Lebensgestaltung außen vor bleibt und zwar in der Erhebung, dass man also,
vorher dafür sorgt, dass diese Manze im Schlafsauber, ja, ich meine, man kann auch Sex in der Küche haben oder im Auto. Also es gibt nicht, kommen sie auf den Raum an, sondern es kommt einfach durchs Persönliche an, dass die vorher sogenannte Kernbereichsprognose machen. Also abschätzen wird hier
eine richtig höchstpersönliche Gespräch geführt oder eben,
Ja. Das ist jetzt, ich sage jetzt immer Sex, aber da geht's natürlich auch um Gespräche zum Beispiel mit seinem Psychologen oder eben mit seinem Partner oder so, also eben, wo man wirklich höchstpersönlich hätte, ja.
Wird hier in dieser Küche.
Äh die Prognose ist immer so eine Sache, ja? Die also.
Die Sendung nicht zu früh ab.
Also die da kommt jedenfalls die Debatte her, dass man da sich natürlich schon,
einfach man hatte technische Möglichkeiten im Wohnraum abzuhören, aber wie macht man das eigentlich, denn der dieser absolute Schutz ist ja der Punkt dran
darf in diesem höchstpersönlichen Bereich gar nicht eingreifen. Egal was Menschen vorgeworfen wird. Und ist natürlich mit den Jahren glaube ich sehr stark verbessert. Und dazu hat leider der erste Staatsräume am Urteil schon beigetragen,
Weil die Richter eigentlich auch zurecht erkannt haben, na ja, aber technisch, wenn ich so eine Wanze, also wenn ich,
dieses Informationstechnische Gerät infiltriere, kann ich jetzt denke ich technisch schlecht ausschließen. Äh und dann gibt's halt noch.
Geburt dieser Idee der Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung oder.
Die ist ja ein bisschen vorher entstanden. Die haben sie sich ja in der politischen Debatte um den Trojaner ausgedacht, dass sie halt einen haben wollen. Äh nämlich die sogenannte Quellen-TKÜ, also
Quellen, Tegel, Kommunikationsüberwachung, die nur laufende Kommunikation abhören soll und den anderen Trojaner, der im Prinzip,
die gesamte Festplatte abschnorchern kann. Das ist ja so ein politischer Unterscheidung.
Und ähm nochmal kurz also zweitausendacht wurde entschieden, beides geht oder.
Na ja das Gesetz war damals verfassungswidrig und nicht komplett. Aber,
Sie haben sich natürlich in der Urteilsbegründung, wie sie es eben immer machen, darüber Gedanken gemacht, wie man verfassungskonform regeln konnte. Und genau det ist sozusagen im BKA-Gesetz dann. Da verwendet worden.
Das ist ja der, also der eigentlich der normale Lauf, so,
Na ja, den kannst du ja nicht verhindern, ne? Wenn dir, wenn dein äh du du machst du machst ein Gesetz
Das Gesetz landet vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, das Bundesverfassungsgericht kommt seiner Aufgabe nach, äh dieses äh Gesetz auf Verfassungskonformität zu prüfen, dann kommt zu dem Ergebnis dieses Gesetz ist
nicht verfassungsgemäß und begründet das ja und eine Begründung, warum etwas nicht verfassungsgemäß ist, ist ja gleichzeitig eine eine Anleitung,
wie man es verfassungsgemäß machen kann, beziehungsweise wo die Grenzen sind, äh die man beim zweiten Anlauf nicht überschreiten darf. Ähm.
Was sie ja nicht geschafft haben.
Genau, aber das sehen wir ja bei.
Na ja, also wir hätten ja der zweite Urteil jetzt nicht, wenn nicht wie der Teil der verfassungswidrig wären, also der Urteil das neue Urteil sagt er, dass eben Teile wie der Verfassungswidrig sind. Also haben sie sozusagen ja die gesteckten Grenzen aus dem ersten Urteil gerade nicht beachtet.
Da kommen wir ja, kommen wir ja gleich nochmal zu. Also.
Aber ich finde nee, mir das eigentlich in der Sache auch bestreiten. Ich finde nicht, dass er der normale Weg ist.
Ich sage nicht, dass ich den gut finde, aber es ist nicht ist es nicht das, was wir auch bei der,
Datenspeicherung in ähnlicher Form sehen ähm und ich sage mal, das ist der Weg, den man sieht, ob das jetzt normal oder unnormal ist, äh aber es ist das, was in der Regel passiert. Ja, es wird, es passiert nicht, dass ein Gesetz ähm,
begründet,
vom Bundesverfassungsgericht zurückgewiesen wird und die Urheber oder Proponenten des Gesetzes sagen, ach Mist ja okay, äh wir wir sind äh verfassungswidrige Leute, wir müssen mal unsere Hausaufgaben machen, sondern die sagen, okay, unsere Hausaufgabe lautet,
Gesetz so schreiben, dass die uns nicht mehr reinfunken, ja?
Genau, es sind natürlich jetzt in den letzten Jahren mit den fünfzehn Urteilen, wo sie auf den Deckel gekriegt haben. Äh sechzehn, wenn man das Luftsicherheitsgesetz mitzählt, äh nicht so richtig geglückt.
Es gibt ja also es gibt ja auch immer wieder von den von den Hardcore Leuten der CDU dann die Forderung, dass man irgendwie was gegen diese gegen dieses Bundesverfassungsgericht unternehmen muss, ne? Das ist ja auch irgendwie eine Forderung, die immer mal wieder äh gestellt wird. Ich glaube, äh.
Liebes Grüße aus Warschau, sage ich nur.
Not aus Ungarn.
Und aus Ungarn. Ja, also es ist äh ist so ist so so ein so ein perfider Weg, so. Ist so gewisser, also ich weiß nicht, ob man das so als Faulheit,
einstufen soll, so nach dem Motto, daher egal, wir machen's jetzt mal nicht so viel Gedanken darüber, wir schreiben einfach mal alles rein, was wir gerne hätten und dann gucken wir mal, was davon durchkommt so. Ja, oder ob das eben auch so kalkül ist so. Ja, wir wollen einfach hier die maximale Verschärfung haben
und dann lassen wir da halt die äh Jungs in Karlsruhe da mal was subtrahieren und fertig. So.
Nee, was wenn du mal struktureller an sich seid, Prozess? Hast du ja eigentlich dann den Effekt, dass du die Grenzen,
Verfassungsgemäß erlaubten, ja immer weiter Dienst, immer weiter, weil du ja immer wieder nimmst die Grenze und kopierst jetzt ins Gesetz. Na ja und damit, also da findet ja eine Ausdehnung statt.
Ja und alles, alles was auch nur gerade soeben noch reinpasst, ist sozusagen auch sofort das, was man jetzt auch für angemessen hält. Und das ist natür.
Und sie haben mir mehr darein gepastet, sonst wäre es ja nicht wie der verfassungswidrig, ja äh ist schon ein interessanter äh Prozess.
Nicht schön, müsse eigentlich müsste eigentlich Punkteabzug kriegen,
na ja stell mal vor so jeder Minister hätte sozusagen nur so fünf Verfassungspunkte so für seine Legislatur und,
ne, wenn man halt so äh so einen, so einen Reinfall erleidet, dann kriegt man halt schon mal einen abgezogen und irgendwann hat man halt einfach keine mehr, also dann darf man irgendwie,
nicht mehr mitspielen oder so.
Verfassungssünder äh Register in Bielef.
Ja genau, so ein so ein Flensburg für Verfassungssünder.
Äh ich fürchte, so lange sind die im waren ja gar nicht im Amt, oder?
Ja, mal gucken.
Also ich meine, wir erinnern uns jetzt gerne sehr zu sagen im zweitausendneun, Kraft getreten zweitausendacht gemacht worden, ja. Da waren ja ganz andere Leute, als sozusagen heute da macht.
Aber so eine MPU könnte man dann vielleicht doch schon mal anordnen oder?
Dominik prinzipiell dafür, dass man die äh ja.
Okay, also aber was wie war die Stimmung nach dem Urteil zweitausendacht, da war sie ja wahrscheinlich eigentlich ganz gut, die Stimmung, ich meine, neues Grundrecht.
Fast euphorisch. Wir haben niemand hättet erwartet, dass erneut Grundrecht gibt, das machen die jetzt sowas alle fünfundzwanzig Jahre im Schnitt. Das war ja klar, also wir haben uns sehr gefreut. Wir hatten auch keine Ahnung, wie ignoriert,
das werden würde. Äh ich glaube alle haben an dieses Volksfindungsurteil gedacht und dann das Grundrecht, ob man zu einer Selbstbestimmung, das hat ja unglaubliche Wirkung gehabt
Für für X Gesetze in Berlin in einer juristischen Bibliothek der kannst du ja unsere Regale da haben sich Juristen unglaublich mit auseinandergesetzt und übrigens hat das auch außerhalb von Deutschland eine hohe Wirkung gehabt. Und so haben alle erwartet
tatsächlich.
Was genau hat so eine hohe Wirkung.
Na das Grundrecht der verdammten Selbstbestimmung. Und so haben alle erwartet, dass dieses Grundrecht auch unglaublich ausstrahlt.
Müssen wir vielleicht kurz erklären, Grundrecht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung, welches Jahrzehnt neunzehnhundert.
Also das war neunzehnhundertfünfundachtzig, also eigentlich vierundachtzig, er war sozusagen genau an der an der Grenze zum äh zur zum Jahreswechsel und ähm dieses Recht äh war sogenannte Volkssehnungsurteil,
und eigentlich besagt es, dass jeder selbst darüber bestimmen darf, wer was über einen weiß, ja? Und die Daten über einen hat. Es waren eine fundamental geile Idee,
und da haben sich halt auch viele andere Länder deutsche Gericht,
also Fassungsgericht ist halt oft relativ weit vor, sodass sich natürlich auch Juristen in nationalem mit neuen Konzepten auseinandersetzen, wie natürlich der auch deutsche Juristen mit anderen Konzep,
Und ich glaube, die Erwartung war damals, äh also zweitausendacht, als Staatsröhrner oder mit dem Grundrecht kam. Erstet auch eine ebenso breite Wirkung haben würde,
Denn sie haben mehr gesagt als nur äh was zu dem Trojaner, denn diese Gewährleistung der Vertraulichkeit und Integrität ist,
genauso auch auf Festplatten beschlagnahme übertragbar, steht sogar dem Urteil drin.
Man könnte ja sagen, also geht ja nicht nur darum, wenn sie einen Rechner infiltrieren durch ein durch einen Trojaner, sondern auch wenn sie der eine Platte durchsuchen und dann informationstechnisch System, was sie beschlagnahmt haben. Es wäre eigentlich jetzt in der ganzen,
Apple FBI Debatte um äh die ganzen Kryptowar zwei null Debatten, die jetzt überall geführt werden. Ähm toller Anhaltspunkt
Aber man muss leider sagen, dass Nigurspondenz nur ganz wenige auch im akademischen Bereich gibt, die sich damit intensiv auseinandergesetzt haben. Es gibt es gibt da tolle auch äh tolle Sachen zu lesen, aber sehr, sehr, sehr wenig. Im Vergleich zu dem Grundrecht der informationelle Selbstbestimmung.
Passiert ist mit dem Urteil, dass man zweitausendneun mit einem BKA-Gesetz kam. Also genau das, der zweitausendacht eigentlich ein Urteil über Landesgesetzgebung und zweitausendneun wird diese
Urteilsbegründung herangezogen, um,
vielleicht auch nicht herangezogen, wie wir in dem noch weiter im weiteren Verlauf sehen, ähm um ein BKA-Gesetz zu setz.
Na, zweitausendacht schon, noch im selben Jahr, also es hat in zweitausendneun in Kraft getreten.
Und in diesem Gesetz wurden die in diesem Verfahren behandelten Themen eben auf Bundesebene ausgerollt als äh Rechte, die das Bundeskriminalamt erlangt.
Also zum einen eben der Trojaner für die sogenannte Unterdurchsuchung, die gesamte Platte, der Trojaner, der sich Quellentickerü nennt, für die laufenden Kommunikationsvorgänge, aber eben sehr, sehr, sehr viel mehr.
Warum sind die? Warum sind die beiden so getrennt? Äh oder wie sind die ähm,
in der Verwaltung getrennt. Es gibt was, also wenn ich das Recht erinnere, gibt es eben für die Online-Durchsuchung eine sehr viel höhere rechtliche Hürde als für die äh Quellen TK.
Korrekt. Genau. Also es geht genau auf dieses Urteil äh aus zweitausendacht zurück.
Und ist das wahrscheinlich deckt sich das mit den mit den Verwaltungsrechtlichen Hürden, die man bei einer Hausdurchsuchung oder einem Telefonabhören hat, oder?
Ähm die Hürden für die Online-Durchsuchung sind eher in dem Bereich, äh wie eben Navance im Schlafzimmer, also sehr, sehr hohe Hürden. Man muss den Kernbereich beachten, man muss eine Prognose machen, also,
ob man höchstpersönlich jetzt abgreift. Dagegen ist natürlich auch verstoßen worden,
Fällen, die wir später erfahren haben, also etwa, dass man äh Cybersex aufgezeichnet hat oder so. Äh und auch transkrebiert hat und so weiter. Äh also solche Dinge muss man eher, na ja, das ist ja der Hund ein zweiter Verstoß,
Du kannst einmal aufzeichnen, höchstpersönlich, du kannst transkribiert. Zweimal gegen die Menschenwürde verstößt. Ähm
die hören dort also verdammt hoch und entsprechend wie man beim großen Lauschangriff hat, also die waren so im Schlafzimmer, gibt's halt bloß sehr, sehr wenige Fälle, wo sie das eben machen. Fünf, sechs im Jahr, sieben
Bei der Quellen-TKÜ haben sie aber gesagt, nein, da geht's doch nur um Kommunikation. Da brauchen wir sozusagen diese Hürden nicht Ansätze. So kommt auch die Trennung zustande. Es sollte,
wird sie auch heute wieder sagen, ich muss halt auch praktikabel sein, als wenn sozusagen die Verfassung irgendwas über äh die Praktikabilität der Menschenwürde sagt,
Aber also die die Trennung kommt aber natürlich auch so ein bisschen von, muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen, von dem Markt, der existiert,
ist natürlich auch viel billiger, Trojaner zu kaufen, der eben nur Skype abschnorchelt.
Ist das so? Ich wenn ich einen Trojaner bauen müsste, wäre diese Skype Sache irgendwie mehr Arbeit als einen, der einfach mir nur vollkommene Rechte auf dem Rechner gibt.
Na ja, Glaube ist einfach rechtlich äh untechnisch besser einzuhegen,
Ähm wenn man eben ähm die Funktionsbeschränkung, wenn man die zu sagen, äh mit mit einbaut,
auch den Auftrag gibt etwa eine kommerzielle Firma, also ich will hier an dieses Gelb AP oder ich möchte an den Browser, weil ich sehen will, wie jemand ihm jetzt eintippt. Also da da ist glaube ich Auftragsprofil an einen äh Auftragnehmer
geringer und damit ist das Produkt mit der.
Zweitausendneun tritt dieses Gesetz in Kraft. Das ist äh eine Zeit, zu der diese ganze Überwachungsgeschichte wirklich viele Menschen ähm sehr stark besch.
Kochte absolut hoch. Ich muss das mal ich glaube, vergisst man. Das eine ist, wir haben intensiv über diesen André Holmfall, den sogenannten hundertneunundzwanzig A Fall.
also diesem Sozialwissenschaftler, dem Soziologen, dem äh vorgeworfen wurde, äh Mitglied einer terroristischen und sogar Kopf einer terroristischen Vereinigung zu sein. Der hundertneunundzwanzig A, der Strafprozessordnung
dreht sich nämlich genau um terroristische Vereinigungen.
Basis einer Tech-Cloud sozusagen. Ja.
Und da war, waren aber sehr viel mehr Fälle. Äh also es gab
mindestens vier verschiedene komplexe wo sie äh diesen Paragraph benutzt haben, um gegen Leute im äh gerade auf so linken Umfeld, wegen Terrorismus
die gesamte technische äh Überwachungs ähm Maschinerie auszupacken. Etwa eine heiße Diskussion damals. Äh Andre Holm war auch in Haft gekommen. Äh da hat die
äh die Presse auch sehr erstaunlicherweise, das ist ja nicht immer so, sozusagen, gerade in linken Zusammenhängen äh sehr wohlwollend berichtet, äh
später wurde die hat sozusagen auch zurückgenommen.
Andre Heum hatte zum Thema der Gentrification von Städten ähm und oder Stadtteilen äh sehr viel geforscht. Forscht da immer noch zu betreibt,
äh Gentref Gentriefication Blog und ich, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, ging es da, wie hießen die autonome Gruppe oder wie hieß die militante Gruppe? Und die hat.
Also MG hat man immer gesa.
Ja, ja, genau, MG.
Die hatten in ihren Texten äh Wörter benutzt, die ähm die Terrorismusfahnder
nicht kannten und dann haben sie diese Wörter gegoogelt und sind auf die Texte von Andre Holm gekommen und haben gesagt, hier da steht doch gentrification, so äh so ungefähr lief das und dann haben sie eben angefangen ihn und seine Lebenspartnerin und Kinder und was.
Dumm, wenn er da ist. Es waren ungefähr insgesamt zweitausend Menschen von den von allen hundert äh Verfahren dem Bereich, weil die ganzen Kontaktpersonen natürlich mitabgehört wurden.
werden dann Sprachgutachten gemacht und also innerhalb des PK um festzustellen, ob das wahrscheinlich ist, dass also andere Holm und andere diese Bekennerschreiben geschrieben haben, in dem Gutachten kam raus aus, davor gar keine Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt. Sie haben trotzdem weitermittelt. Vor allen Dingen äh war hier eine sehr enge
Quickung zwischen dem Verfassungsschutz und Polizeiarbeit. Ist ja in Deutschland immer sehr fragwürdig. Wir haben ja ein Trennungsgebot
Also das eben Geheimdienst von Polizei aufgrund ihrer unterschiedlichen Aufgaben, aber auch Möglichkeiten äh nicht eng zusammenarbeiten sollen. Ähm hier
waren die Verfassungsschutzbehörden in vielen der Fälle einfach äh hinmessgeber, haben auch teilweise sehr eng zusammengearbeitet.
Der hatte dieser Fall eigentlich noch äh rechtliche Konsequenzen nicht so wirklich, oder? Die einzige rechtliche Konsequenz war, dass man ähm.
Jetzt so eine andere Holmfahrt leer. Ähm na auf jeden Fall äh zu sagen, er ist ein Haft gekommen und äh,
genau und also da waren ja schossen sich mehrere Gewichtsverfahren an. Das war rechtswidrig. Ähm,
Also das wurde auch irgendwann richtig eingestellt, das hat aber mehrere Jahre gedauert. Ähm ich weiß aber nicht, ob es juristisch schon zu Ende ist oder ob äh äh zu sagen die
die ehemals Beschuldigten immer noch versuchen da auch mal eine Entschädigung zu bekommen. Also das weiß ich nicht ob
ob da zwischendurch jegliche, juristische Verfahren schon abgeschlossen ist. Aber es gab mal eine relativ
große Soliwelle. Da waren aber auch noch sozusagen Öko-Terroristen dabei. Denn einige der hundertneunundzwanzig A Felder waren äh aus dem äh G Widerstand und waren aber auch teilweise sozusagen Gruppen, die sich für äh bäuerliche Landwirtschaft einsetzen. Das war eine relativ breite Spektrum.
Ja. Ich sehe auch gerade Piratenpartei, hatte damals Erste, die haben irgendwie bei der zweitausendneuner Bundestagswahl zwei Prozent geholt und hatten sich damit von dieser,
Europa. Oh je, dann habe ich hier gerade kurz.
Auf jeden Fall gab's da große Demos, also die technisierte Überwachung war einfach ein richtiges Thema zu der Zeit.
Genau, also es war,
Piratenpartei, wir haben die sind durchgedreht und haben irgendwie Soziologen eingesperrt, äh die ja Andre Holm ist, denke ich, kann man einfach sagen, auf diesem, auf diesem Forschungsgebiet gibt's einfach, glaube ich, keinen, der so viel
Renomee hat wie er, dass.
Ich glaube sehr andersrum. Gott sei Dank ist das so, dass sich viele für das Thema dann interessiert haben. Ich glaube, der Begriff war vorher wenigen bekannt. Ist eigentlich ganz schön, dass sozusagen diese diese akademische Disziplin so ja.
Ähm aber also er hatte auf jeden Fall ich war zu der Zeit auch an dem äh an den Instituten, habe da ein paar Seminare besucht
und dann hing da irgendwie am Institut für Sozialwissenschaften der Humboldt Universität zu Berlin an die Musik lassen. Wir wollen hier wieder unser Seminar weitermachen. Also also es kochte, es kochte hoch in der Zeit knallen die dann irgendwie so ein Gesetz rein und sagen jo äh,
Und dann passierte erstmal lange Zeit nicht wirklich was, ne? Weil man nicht wusste, wie weit ist das BKA mit dem,
umsetzen.
Nee, nein, nein, die Verfassungsbeschwerden müssen ja innerhalb eines Jahres erfolgen, sind sie auch. Ähm das hat, also das hat halt ewig beim Gericht gelegen. Die Anhörung war dann eben erst zweitausendfünfzehn.
Wie kommt es, dass da sechs Jahre lang nichts geschehen ist.
Nein, man kann nicht sagen, dass da nichts geschehen ist. Also ich meine, äh,
So viel Bekanntes über die äh sozusagen Arbeit des Gerichts äh wartet natürlich auch sehr komplex äh unglaublich viele Paragraphen, die da angegriffen wurden ins verschiedene äh Probleme, die die Verfassungsbeschwerden, also zwei Verfassungsbeschwerden
da aufgegriffen haben und äh intern sollten riesengroßes Gutachten geben, wenn man die Berichterstatter erstellt hat mit mehreren hundert Seiten. Also ist ja auch eine Menge Arbeit.
warum das so ewig gedauert hat weiß ich nicht.
Der Chaos-Computerclub hat dann in diese Zeit genutzt ähm mal so einen Staatstrojaner äh zu analysieren, zu veröffentlichen, ein Gutachten darüber zu schreiben,
Es war der äh Trojaner äh des Herstellers äh Digitas, der in Bayern zum Einsatz kam oder.
Mittlerweile wissen wir, dass er ja in sehr viel sehr viel mehr, also er kam ungefähr bundesweit oh hundert Mal zum Einsatz, also aber,
bestimmter Fall, der mit diesem Digitalstreuern zusammenhängt, der wurde dann in der Öffentlichkeit besprochen, der sogenannte Landshutfall und der betraf halt Bayern.
Ja stellte sich die das ist hinhinlänglich bekannt. Ich versuche das nur mal so zusammenzufassen. Äh es gab diese Analyse. Es gab eine sehr äh ausführliche Berichterstattung ähm in der Faz,
damals angetrieben von,
Gott hab ihn selig, der ähm dieses Thema äh wusste ähm,
zu setzen und jetzt in den medialen Kontext zu setzen, der äh durch diesen Abdruck äh des des Quellcodes ähm beziehungsweise des des des des des Binarys oder war das das.
Wenn du so willst der, ja.
Des desazemblierten Codes ähm da irgendwie eine das war einfach eine,
der hat das geschafft, dieses Thema zu setzen. Das war und der Chaoscomputerclub natürlich auch mit seiner Arbeit, aber das hat medial äh gezündet wie äh nichts Gutes.
Wer im Ergebnis war klar, dass äh dieser Trojaner handwerklich einfach totale Grütze war, dass er aber vor allen Dingen äh ganz klar gemacht hat, dass der rechtliche Schrank über also überschritten wurden.
Das war nämlich der wichtige, ob das jetzt halt, also ich meine, die die handwerkliche Qualität der polizeilichen Ermittlungswerkzeuge ist äh grundsätzlich kein ähm,
kein, kein, keine nichts, dass der Chaos-Computerclub sich auf die Schade geschrieben hat, unbedingt zu verbessern, ja. Äh das heißt, aber es, das war ja eher so ein äh interessanter Nebenaspekt, dass man über die Qualit,
auch lachen konnte, ne?
Na ja, also zwei Aspekte dazu. Also zum einen äh wir haben ja gezeigt, man kann auch ein Commerce Control Server bauen und damit hast du natürlich immer so ein paar Probleme, die sich aus handwerklichen Fehlern ergeben, die sehr wohlwisse. Ja, also es ist
schon so, wenn du zeigen kannst, wie einfache Dritte haben, so einen Staatstrainer zu übernehmen, hattet natürlich auch wieder rechtliche, genau.
Genau, aber die der Kern der äh der,
Der Kern dieser Veröffentlichung war ja, dass dieser Trojaner Funktion hatte, die laut zweitausendachter Urteil und auch laut zweitausendneuner Gesetz äh einfach nicht,
Die waren einfach rechtswidrig. So, ne? Und wie gesagt, Qualität ist, ist eine Randnotiz vor dem Hintergrund, dass.
Es ging nach auch noch im dritten Nachladen. Das war der dritte, der dritte Punkt, dass man eben also einfach auch Code nachladen konnte. Und damit äh man ja aus
Ja, da, also A aus einer Quellentickerüse, leicht eine Onlineuntersuchung machen kann, aber vor allen Dingen hattet ihr auch mal Beweissicherheit zu tun, man hat ja da auch Beschuldigte und so. Also ich meine, die müssen sicher vielleicht auch später vor Gericht werden, solche solche Dinge. Da,
Menge,
nimm ja eine Menge kritische äh Probleme, die man daran zitieren musste, vor allen Dingen, also letztlich standen die natürlich mit darunter gelassenen Husen war, weil es ja auch peinlich ist.
Das war, das war durchaus peinlich.
Und rechtsbrüchig.
Genau das denke ich ist eben der der wichtige Punkt, der auch dazu geführt hat, dass dieses ähm dieses Tool nicht mehr genutzt wurde, nicht mehr genutzt werden durfte. Sofort. War das als.
Na ja, also gut, also zum einen jeder Viren, ja, jeder Viren äh Dings da, was die Leute auf Windows haben. Er hat natürlich eine Schlag.
Es ging halt auch nicht mehr, ja.
Na wir hatten auch den lustigen Vorfall, das uns so viele Leute hatten uns geschrieben, weil die haben sich ja drunter geladen und dann sprang deren also sprangen deren, was wie heißt du denn bei Windows, wenn man äh Schaden,
Genau. Ich brenne die halt an.
Wie heißt das denn bei Windows.
Nee, ist egal. Also jedenfalls schrieben uns. Leute, sie, oh ja, wir haben jetzt hier den Schatz, wenn jemand hat den bei uns insadiert, der Whey, du hast ihn gerade runtergeladen. Wir haben, wir haben da, darüber teilweise ganz lustig.
Ähm,
Genau, dann stand dann äh gegen das Theater los. Äh wir haben keinen Trojaner mehr. Wir müssen jetzt irgendwie gucken, wo wir einen herkriegen
Es gab relativ ausführliche ähm,
Dann auch immer wieder durch Leaks und Artikel dokumentierte Bemühungen, unterschiedlicher äh staatlicher Behörden äh sich bei den üblichen Verdächtigen, ähm die ja äh in,
hauptsächlich in weiß ich im nahen Osten ein guten Ruf haben dort Trojaner, ein Diktatoren zu verkaufen, sich bei denen mal zu erkundigen. Wir sehen in den
liegst über von Gama von vor ein, zwei Jahren,
vom wir sehen die auch dokumentiert die Gespräche die Verträge, es gab dann irgendwie.
Team hat teilweise genau.
Genau, bei Hacking Team gab's in den E-Mails, die äh die Kontakte zu.
Genau in der Nacht vor vor der Anhörung. Ich hab das noch an dem Morgen ich hab noch versucht runterzuladen und ich war so blödes Hotelnetz. Äh ich habe tatsächlich noch versucht anzubringen in der Anhörung,
aber.
Ich erinnere mich noch, dass wir da Abend.
Genau. Aber der der Punkt war auch noch, dass natürlich äh Front des Staatstreuer nach Hax äh zwei sehr wichtige Gutachten entstanden, denn sie jetzt auf Wiederverwendung fand. Nämlich einmal, dass der damalige Bundesbeauftragte Schar, also als zwar noch einen hatten sozusagen,
Übrigens, Frau Possof hat wieder gefehlt, weder also sie war weder bei der Anhörung noch vor jeder Hotelzerkündigung.
Es gab aber eine PM von ihrem Mitarbeiter.
Unsere super Datenschützerin.
Ja. Na jedenfalls damals war der Schara und er hat natürlich einen sehr interessanten Bericht geschrieben, der ihm auch äh äh der hatte zum Beispiel drin diesen äh Fall mit dem Telefonsex
und der Transkription des Telefonzecks. Also es gab einfach auch eine gewisse Untersuchung. Der war allerdings geheim, der wurde dann vom CC geliegt, dieser Bericht,
Und es gab auch noch einen Bericht, der ging jetzt auch, hat natürlich in in dieser Anhörung einen vom bayerischen äh
Datenschutzbeauftragten, die haben dann einfach auch mal hingeguckt. Das war ziemlich wichtig. Und die haben übrigens auch alle unsere technischen,
Also im Bericht dargelegten äh technischen Schlussfolgerungen in jedem einzelnen Punkt. Ähm unterstützt. Also da da ist nichts widerlegt worden.
Gab's keinerlei äh Zweifel dran, ne.
Ja, so im Gegenteil, sie haben sogar einen draufgelegt. Wir konnten ja natürlich anhand der des Disco-Semply nicht sehen, ob die äh Telefonsex transkripiert haben, konnten natürlich nur.
Also Frau Vossof äh begrüßt aber das Urteil des Bundesverfassungs.
Wäre ja noch schöner, wenn sie schreibt, dass sie also.
Ich sage nur, also ich habe nur gerade mal geguckt, ob sie sich überhaupt äh geäußert hat, wenn sie schon nicht äh vor Ort war und es gibt hier.
Ein Mitarbeiter war da.
Es gibt dann hier auf dieser Webseite die äh laut Titel Internetauftritt der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten heißt? Ja, gibt's immerhin eine Pressemitteilung,
Meilenstein für den Datenschutz.
Uiui. So, also Staatsreaner Heck haben wir auch. Ähm
Danach dokumentiert sehr sehr ausführliche Bemühungen und wenn ich mich nicht täusche, folgte dann äh
zweitausendfünfzehn jetzt als nächster signifikanter Meilenstein eben die Anhörung zu der Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen das BKA-Gesetz, die angestrengt worden war von
Unserem ehemaligen Innenminister.
Nee, der ist der, also Gerhard Baum ist der Anwalt. Der Beschwerdeführer, der ist nicht der Beschwerdeführer.
Ah okay, wer die Beschwerde.
Zwei Verfassungsbeschwerden und einer ist so eine Gruppe von Ärzten, Journalisten und so, die äh ähm,
ähm einfach ja aufgrund ihrer Berufsgeheimnisträgerfunktion besonders äh dieser dieser dieses Gesetz angegriffen haben und Gerhard Baum und Burka Türsch sind die Anwälte und die zweite Gruppe ist sind ähm,
also Grüne Bundestagsfraktionsmitglieder von dieser Legislatur und da war der Anwalt Synke Hilbrands, äh den man ja auch vom republikanischen Anwaltsfeigen kennt,
Also die, ich habe so ein bisschen unterschiedliche Aspekte, die Verfassungsbeschwerden aber greifen vor allen Dingen also sehr, sehr viele verschiedene Probleme auf,
Also zieht sich der Prinzip, dass da jeder oder fast jeder Paragraph, wo sie dazu bemängeln haben
Sie werden da auch sehr grundsätzlich. Also da geht's eben um um die Frage vor allen Dingen im Kernbereich, aber auch
äh um den Gefahrenbegriff, was ist eigentlich Terrorismus, denn äh viele dieser Normen darf man eben nur gegen den internationalen Terrorismus und wie ist es eigentlich definiert, solche Fragen? Da war eine Menge bei oder auch eben,
Transfer der Daten ins Ausland zwischen den Behörden, wer darf eine Zweckänderung vornehmen, ja, wenn nicht was erlangt haben und so. Also ganz viel, viele viele Defizite juristische Fragen.
Ich finde das ja so spannend, äh wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ähm war doch der Gerhard Baum als ähm Minister,
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland durchaus auch mit Terrorismus beschäftigt, oder? Also der hatte mit der Raff zu tun.
Ja. Richtig, ja. Na ja gut, das hatten aber die Minister vor und nach ihm auch. Es war ja noch eine längere Phase, ja klar.
Ähm aber um jetzt so diese Personalie einzuordnen, weil ich da schon sehr spannend finde als Innenminister,
Der zu Raffzeiten gedient hat, ja, wo wirklich ein Wind äh wehte, der ähm,
Also ne, in der gesamtdeutschen Politik, äh wo kaum noch jemand Spaß verstanden hat, auch er nicht, aber ähm das das jemand ist, der noch wirklich äh Jahrzehnte später äh,
sich für Verfassung,
und Freiheitsrechte als Anwalt äh engagiert. Aber es ist glaube ich auch ganz klar, dass der da jetzt nicht nur als äh Verteidiger oder Anwalt war, sondern der der lebt auch das, was er seine.
Ein ganz zentraler Punkt für sehr, sehr viele Urteile in dieser in dieser Zeit. Also glaube, wer Gerhard Baum bisschen verstehen und er sollte sich zwei Bücher, also es gibt eins, das heißt, meine Wut ist,
Jung, glaube ich, oder meine Mut ist noch jung. Äh und es gibt äh neue Buche, das heißt der Baum und der Hirsch und,
Äh ganz großartig. Äh und es gibt auch einen sehr interessanten Film, der heißt glaube ich, die Anwälte, wo Gerhard Baum, äh Ströbeler und dieser,
so ein so ein so eine Art Doku ist da versteht man glaube ich wie warum warum,
Liberale und Freiheitsliberale was Unterschiedliches sind und wo so die Motivation herkommt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich erzählen kann, aber,
Na, ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch zu privat. Ach, doch, das will ich vielleicht mal erzählen, wenn man so eine kurze Geschichte erzählt aus dem Gebäude rausging nach dem Urteil,
Sagte Gerhard Baum zu mir, wir waren, wir hatten also über uns kurz erstmal über die Uta gesprochen und waren dann auf dem Weg zum Bahnhof, da sagte er, wir müssen was machen gegen diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung der Flugpassagierdaten,
tickt dieser Mann.
Die ähm.
Also wir sind, wir waren da nicht raus, ja, wir hatten noch gar nicht noch gar nicht alles.
Schon beim nächsten Thema sozusagen.
Und die wurde am Dienstag verabschiedet, oder? Donnerstag. Hm. War das und Donnerstag, aber na ja, das kann jeden. Wochenende vor jedem. Ja, äh.
Donnerstag glaube ich. Also die Woche davor jedenfalls. Ja. Also das Urteil war ja jetzt.
Also der war ja jetzt. Hatten wir noch gar nicht befasst, oder? Ja.
Ja. Hatten wir noch gar nicht. Äh Lokwohnnetzpolitik wird bericht.
Das ist ein bisschen aus der Spur gerade, aber wir holen das nach.
Er hat auch Mühe hinterherzukommen, oder?
Ja, ja, es äh die Taktrate ist schon teilweise.
Ich glaube, das Anti-Terror-Paket hättet ihr auch noch nicht unserer aktuellen Koalition, oder? Mh.
Gibt's da schon wieder Neues? Läuft's?
Genau, also man kommt echt.
Irgendwann mal aufhören, wir müssen das hier alles abarbeiten. Ich werde da mal irgendwie den hinschreiben. Das geht ja wohl so nicht.
Genau, liebe Bundesregierung, macht mal ein bisschen langsamer, wir kommen nicht mehr hinterher. Was sollen wir denn das machen? Genau.
Eure Kronisten. Äh.
Eure Netzpolitik, Lokbuchchronisten.
Hm.
Anhörung ähm zweitausendfünfzehn, du kriegst obwohl ja quasi die
Beschwerde sechs Jahre anhängig ist, hast, weiß ich, kann man vielleicht aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern relativ kurzfristig die die Bitte bekommen dort als Sachverständiger aufzutreten, ich glau.
Sind so, dass man hat man klickt ja immer so alle halbe Jahre mal auf die Seite, ob es jetzt bald mal ansteht, weil man auf der Webseite vom vom Verfassungsgericht immer sehen kann, so wird jetzt so die, was kommt nichts zu dir? Und dann kann man aber doch sehr plötzlich äh im im
äh ja, Sommer im Prinzip äh kurz, also das waren halt so drei Wochen, das ist sehr, sehr, sehr knapp.
Und die Sachverständiger haben natürlich alle gestöhnt, also waren ja nicht nur zu sagen, nicht nur der CDC angefragt, äh sondern eben auch noch eine ganze Menge andere, muss man sich so vorstellen, dass man die Bundesrechtsanwaltskamera und ähm ähm,
In dem Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragter, so äh eine Formatikprofessor und so, also man die haben halt alle echt
sehr wenig Zeit gehabt. Zumal, also das Konvolut an Papier war hier noch größer.
Es war eben, was muss man sich vor fünfhundert, sechshundert, siebenhundert, du zeigst jetzt, er geht immer.
Ach so, wir haben ja hier Podcast eine Eisdacht, fünfzehn Zentimeter Papier oder so, also echt enorm.
Haben sie das denn alles gelesen, Frau Doktor Kurz?
Na ja, also ich glaube man äh für mich ist das auch so immer so ein,
also A, äh ich bin kein Jurist, ich möchte verstehen, worüber die sich streiten. Ich glaube, dass man nur eine gute technische Bewertung abgeben kann, wenn man versteht, weil's was der Punkt ist von diesen Juristen. Ähm und im Übrigen habe ich einfach oft mit denen zu tun. Äh.
Zur der Anhörung hat ihr damals damals TM zweitausendfünfzehn auch.
Julei, das ist noch nicht damals.
Äh auch ein Netzpolitik-Podcast gemacht, den es in den Shownotes gibt, da waren glaube ich du und äh Ulf äh Burmeier in bei Netz bei Markus äh zu Gast.
Bei Markus Becker. Mhm.
Hab darüber gesprochen.
Also glücklich war den Abend oder den Tag danach oder so.
Mir hoffen und ähm vielleicht fast ja trotzdem nochmal kurz zusammen, wie es denn da so war für dich.
Na die Anhörung war wieder sehr sehr lang über fünf Stunden und ich bin aber kurz vorm Ende
muss ich auch gehen, weil ich den Zug noch kriegen wollte, also ich habe nicht mal das Ende diesmal mitbekommen. Ähm und waren halt im Prinzip genauso komplex die Anhörung, wie äh
die Beschwerdeführer eben auch schon dahelgt haben. Alles mögliche, ja, also ging sehr viel um den Kernbereich, aber bei ganz, also in diesen sozusagen höchstpersönliche Ebene wieder, aber eben auch bei allen Paragraphen. Äh da kann man ja auch bei der akustischen, optischen Wohnung, Überwachung drüber reden,
den beiden Arten, dass der Trojaner war eben, da war viel mehr
eben Weitergabe von Daten, die man erlangt hat, darf man den Zweck ändern. Unter welchen, unter welchen Voraussetzungen. Und dann aber auch so ganz grundsätzliche Fragen, die da debattiert wurden eben
ja wie ich sage mal, Terrorismus definiert, was ist eine Gefahr? Ähm
der war wirklich eine Menge. Und ähm das wurde aus meiner Sicht war nicht sehr strukturiert abgearbeitet, aber ich hatte halt Glück. Ähm,
Ich war relativ früh dran, so dass ich eigentlich äh die die Argumente, die die wir in die Stellungnahme auch geschrieben haben, auch äh noch gut darlegen konnte. Andere Sachverständige hatten äh teilweise sehr viel weniger Zeit, eben,
war einfach ein bisschen Glück, dass es äh in der Tagesordnung relativ weit vorne war.
Schon ärgerlich, wenn man sich dann davon so etwas nach nach irgendwie so vielen Jahren der Vorbereitung ähm die Sachverständigen so zeitlich unter Druck setzt und dann auch noch irgendwie nur an einem Tag da.
Ja aber zu den Akten genommen waren natürlich auch unser Bericht, der war in den Akten äh auch der Bericht, den Schar gemacht hatte, also den Schatz rein Untersuchungsbericht. Äh da war der Bericht äh,
Von den bayrischen Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten, der hatte die auch geprüft, ein langer Bericht, also der war ja, die lesen ja die Akten. Man schreibt bitte nicht umsonst, selbst wenn man's bei der Annürung nicht sagen kann, aber die Anhörung.
Fragen dann unter Umständen auch, die einfach ihre Verständnis fragen. Zu dem gelesenen, was sie ohnehin schon.
Na, in unserem Fall war das ja nicht so, weil das so knapp war ähm genau, als.
Stimmt, du hattest die war ja jetzt irgendwie einen Tag vorher fertig oder am Tag selber oder ja.
Die versuchen natürlich aber trotzdem ein paar Knackpunkte anzusprechen, aber der Trojaner war eben an Ersatz bei der letzten Anhörung nicht längst nicht das Einzige. Und dann war halt ähm also zwischendurch ist ja auch noch eine sogenannte,
ja eigentlich 'ne Änderung der der Policy beim bei den Polizeien passiert nämlich der Grundsatz war ja jetzt, wir entwickeln auch selbst und Sie haben 'ne Leistungsbeschreibung, da standardisierte Leistungsbeschreibung entworfen und so weit. Das kann man.
Die schon bei dieser Anhörung, ich ja und weil ich das nächste, was nämlich jetzt zur Zeit in der Zeitmarke war, war ja im Februar, glaube ich, diesen Jahres, als dann äh Herr,
Wir haben's, wir sind fertig. So, Commit, make und ähm die haben,
Dann im Februar verkündet fertig zu sein, Staatstrojaner zu haben. Ähm.
Ich war einigermaßen überraschend, einfach war ja klar, weil das Urteil kommt jetzt demnächst, also wussten ja auch eigentlich alle, dass es im Frühjahr irgendwann kommen wird.
Wie kann man sich das erklären, dass sie noch vor Urteilsverkündung so selbstsicher sagen, wir sind fertig, also ist ja auch vielleicht von der äh,
Selbst wenn also nachher stellte sich ja jetzt heraus, dass der Leistungsumfang dieses,
Quellen TK Ü Troianas, den sie da haben, dann doch sehr ähm eingeschränkt ist, was ja wohl durchaus auch richtig sein kann, aber äh wir haben viele äh Quengeleien dann äh gelesen von ähm,
Polizeivertretern, die sagten, da kann man nichts mit anfangen, der kann nur bei Windows Rechnern Skype abh.
Wir hatten zwischendurch vielleicht mal kurz nochmal sagen, da wir hatten ja zwischendurch auch noch dieses Notenanomalie. Und Skype war ja zum Beispiel auch Teil des Notenveröffentlichung
und soweit also dazwischen hat sich ja diese ganze Debatte unnormal verändert, ja. Und die Nutzung, weil so was wir machen mit den Geräten
Und also ich meine, geht es eigentlich nur um Skype? Weil heute, also die Özils mit ihrem Trojaner gehen ja viel mehr auf WhatsApp zum Beispiel. Also der hat sich einfach auch viel verändert in den wenigen Jahren.
Das iPhone kam zweitausendzehn, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, oder? Zweitausendsieben, ah okay, als Rene dann äh also dann kann mein iPhone zweitausendzehn.
Ja, aber du hast das erste iPhone auch nicht benutzt, wie das heute die Leute machen wirst. Also hat sich immer verändert
Und auch, dann dann gab's sozusagen nochmal dieses Jahr, es ist ja letztlich, auch wenn wir nicht zufrieden sind, bestimmt nicht mit den Folgen. Es ist ja schon ein Einschneidensache, dass ich so eine Rundendebatte,
vielen Leuten klar gemacht hat, äh was da eigentlich läuft hinter ihren Rücken. Also das muss man schon sehen, finde ich, dass das auch nochmal eine andere Debatte ist. Heute.
Auf jeden Fall, das hat wirklich auch mal wirklich mal was verändert. Ich meine, diese,
Diskussion wird ja in den Kreisen schon lange geführt, aber ich habe auch so den Eindruck, dass das ich glaub vor allem es hat auch dazu geführt, dass auch in den Kreisen einige ähm,
wie soll ich sagen, Zweifler vielleicht oder etwas zurückhaltender äh argumentierender, die sich auch immer so ein bisschen mit so einem optimistischen, kann ja so schlimm wird's nicht sein, Ding, dass die diese Position äh auch äh weg
spült haben und das ist dadurch auch einfach mehr Verbreitung gefunden haben. Würde ich mich sogar würde ich mich sogar fast selber dazu zählen.
Niemand anders. Jetzt denken alle, ich hätte hier irgendwas fürchterliches gemacht.
Stück weit auf jeden Fall.
Zweitausen,
Aber also was man glaube ich sagen kann als dieses BKA-Gesetz zweitausendneun formuliert wurde ist man wenn man vielleicht an so ein Smartphone gedacht hat haben sie gesagt OK die E-Mails die wir auf dem Computer dann mit unserem Staatstrianer holen äh die,
Können auch auf so einem Telefon abgeholt werden, aber da das hat wahrscheinlich noch keiner sich gedacht, dass es inzwischen einfach für die Menschen wahrscheinlich mehr Daten auf ihren Telefonen gibt,
als auf auf ihrem Computer die für Strafverfolgungsbehörden relevant.
Nee, also ich,
Nee, wirklich nicht. Ich denke, dass äh mit dem Begriff informationstechnischem System, die die damals, ja, das haben wir ja gesetzt den Begriff. Haben die das schon,
also wirklich vor der eigentlichen Debatte schon gesehen, dass es nicht nur um PCs auf dem Schreibtisch geht oder um Laptops.
Internet of Things.
Der Anhörung zweitausendsieben war schon auch schon die Rede von Medizinalgeräten von ja ja. Also das war schon damals klar, dass man da über mehr redet. Etwa nicht gerade, dass wir, glaube ich, in den Computern auch sitzen, ja äh vielleicht also die ganze
ähm Autonomiedebatte, ja, das informationstechnische Geräte auch autonom entscheiden, die war noch nicht,
Aber das war doch schon klar. Und das fällt ihnen ja teilweise jetzt auch wieder auf die Füße, ja. Also das Urteil ist verdammt weitsichtig.
Es ist weitsichtig und es kam vor allem auch zu einem
sehr interessanten Zeitpunkt, weil wenn man sich auch mal anschaut, wie man das Smartphone heißt ja jetzt nicht nur, dass da ähm die Daten etwas geballter vorliegen, sondern es ist ja auch eine ganz andere Qualität von Privatsphäre, die sich dort eigentlich abzeichnet.
Die Sensorik kommt dazu, du hast genau. Ja.
Genau. Warauf wollte ich hinaus, ne? Also das einfach äh auf einmal Daten anfallen, die ja so mit einem Desktop-Rechner einfach überhaupt gar nicht äh auch nur hingekommen sind. Also nicht nur Bewegungsdaten, sondern mittlerweile kann das Ding ja,
alles erfassen. Bis hin eben auch.
Ziehung hat sich verändert.
Gesundheitsdaten et ceter.
Ja klar, also Leute, ich glaube auch die Beziehung von dem Mensch zu dem Gerät ist auch nochmal anders. Also ist ja klar irgendwie, wir hatten da auch schon eine Mobiltelefone, aber so diese ist halt mein,
organisiere damit mein Leben ja und meiner Kommunikation das ist noch viel stärker finde ich.
Viele Leute ist das Leben. Absolut.
Sollte man vielleicht da zusehen, ne? Also die Zeit ist halt,
Auch wenn wir auch damals schon irgendwie in Digitalien gelebt haben oder trotzdem nochmal anders, finde ich. Und ist ja auch kein Zufall, dass wir heute wieder diese Kryptowar-Debatte haben und diese Riesendebatte über Apple und FBI,
Letztlich es viele davon schon im alten Urteil durchaus äh angelegt.
Wie was sagen wir denn jetzt zu dem Urteil, was gestern gesprochen wurde?
Zum Kern der Sache, wa?
Kommen wir zum Thema. Und nun zu etwas völlig anderem. Nein, jetzt wurde gestern geurteilt. Ähm.
Ist ja immer so ein lustiger Moment.
Medien, Medienecho ist dann irgendwie so äh Bundesverfassungsgericht stärkt äh Grundrechte oder äh.
Du musst mir mal das Medienecho sagen, ne? Gestern, ich hatte so viel zu tun, dass wir eigentlich überhaupt nicht, sagt mir mal, was ist eigentlich aus eurer Sicht, ihr habt ja bestimmt dann irgendwie live mitgekriegt, was ist denn das Echo? Da drin sind nämlich Mobiltelefone verboten. Sagen die auch an.
Ja, na ja gut.
Wie die sind verboten.
Man darf die nicht benutzen, während äh der Verlesung des Urteils.
Ach so, ah okay, sorry, ich dachte jetzt in dem Urteil, wenn jetzt mobiltelefone, das w.
Nein, denn äh nee, ich meine nur, also was man nicht mach.
Das haben die nicht berichtet.
Was man nicht machen kann, ist halt äh.
Ja, dann war's das mit der Liebe fürs Verfassungsgericht.
Also ich habe, ich sage mir mal, was der Tenor war, was habt ihr denn mitgekriegt sozusagen am Vormittag und Mittag dann.
Also ähm ich denke, die.
Ich habe das nicht so live äh mitgetickert jetzt.
Ich kann jetzt mal so ein bisschen über also Überwachungskritisches Urteil.
Habe ich selber geschrieben,
Ah nee, das ist aber auch sechzehn Uhr irgendwat.
jetzt gehe ich, ihr seid so gemein.
BKA Gesetz teilweise verfassungswidrig, Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgericht, was sich beim BKA-Gesetz ändern muss.
haben wir wieder dieses normal, ne? Da ist da wird schon direkt selbst die Tagesschau berichtet schon völlig ganz klar. So, wir haben hier, wir wissen jetzt, was geändert werden muss. Äh Demazier, ähm der Bundesinnenminister ähm sprach eben von Bedenken, die er nicht teilt.
Tja ist schön, ne?
Das ist gut, dafür sprach ähm,
Jetzt sprach Gerd Baum dann äh von äh Bedenken, die aber dann für ihn mitteilt und ähm,
Klatsche für die Koalition Teil Erfolg für Bürgerrechte wurde bei heiße Online getitelt,
dann melden sich natürlich die Vertreter der Polizeigewerkschaften ich glaub in dem Fall was Andre Schulz denn sagt wir brauchen Gesetze die praktikabel sind aber was wirklich so ein bisschen fehlte war,
eine also ich glaube das Thema wurde öffentlich jetzt nicht so aufbereitet, dass man das, sage ich mal so, beim Überfliegen,
eingängig versteht, was eben wahrscheinlich auch an dem an diesem Ausmaß äh dieses Gesetzes und auch das ist das Urteil, was wir.
Ich hab's mitgebracht. Ich habe sozusagen vor mir.
Beidseitig bedruckt.
Ähm das ist beidseitig bedruckt.
Es waren, ich glaube, das waren ohne Anhänger hundertvierzig Seiten, ohne Anlagen.
Also ein Zentimeter.
Nee so hundertachtzehn Seiten und eigentliche Urteil, aber wir hängen dahinten noch zwei Sonderboten dran, weil.
Die Sonne wohnten hängen auch noch dran und dann sind's ja.
Kommt schon hin, hundertvierzig Tage.
Was sind Sondervoten.
Äh die Entscheidung ist fünf zu drei ergangen und zwei der ähm Richter haben in also diese Runde wurden abgegeben, die haben halt also bestimmte Aspekte des Urteils nicht mittragen wollen und haben in den Sondervoten dargelegt, welche und warum.
Da hast du das schon angeschaut und mal geguckt, in welche Richtung die gehen.
Selbstverständlich die haben äh Prinzip,
ich würde mal, äh, wird mal allgemein sagen, ist natürlich teilweise auch wieder juristisch enstinfiziert, aber im Wesentlichen sagen sie, dass ihnen die Regelungen zu konkret sind. Manche von den Aussagen, zu manchen Paragraphen lehnen sie ab und begründen sie dann im Einzelnen,
Also im Wesentlichen ist der Teenor äh so viel
konkrete Vorschriften sollte man äh nicht machen. Vor allen Dingen auch nicht so eine ausziesilierten. Das ist so ein bisschen der Tenor dieser Sonderboden,
Also einer der beiden Sonder.
Ist das eine ästhetisches Argument oder haben ähm wie.
Och na ja, du kannst natürlich kannst du jetzt Richter der Meinung sein, ich folge diesem dem Urteil nicht, weil ist viel zu genau, so Dirk kann man die Polizeiarbeit nicht einschränken, du kannst zu einer anderen Einschätzung kommen, äh.
Das heißt, sie sind, die sind eher äh also ihre Argumentation ist eher, dass das Urteil nicht so stark einschränken sollte. Okay, das das genau, ist halt, weil jetzt.
Also tendenziell schließen sie sich sozusagen der Mehrheit nicht so an und hätten da eher noch ein Auge zugedrückt.
Es gibt halt immer noch so ähnliche Anhaltspunkte, nämlich die Kostenübernahme,
Ist ein interessanter Punkt, äh wenn nämlich jetzt Gericht sagt, äh wir setzen den Beschwerdeführern die Kosten, dann haben sie im Wesentlichen Erfolg errungen.
Ja äh dann und deshalb ist es also es ist immer so, du legst uns als Erfolg aus oder hatten sie eigentlich keinen Erfolg? Ich meine, wenn du eine Anhörung hast, fährst du immer
das sind ein paar Sachen, die sind, nehmen sie ernst und die werden sich verfassungswidrig erklären. Aber wenn dann ernst am Ende die Kostenentscheidung kommt und du kriegst die Kosten ersetzt als Beschwerdeführer, dann weißt du auch, dass sie im Wesentlichen,
bist du durchgedrogen? Ja, sie, also die Kosten werden übernommen. Hast äh wesentlichen Punkten sind sie durchgekommen,
Also so ist ein interessanter Mitteljuristen erzählt heute ganz interessant. Äh dann ist ja nicht immer so, ne? Wenn du nicht durchtrinkst, dann äh ist das dein Problem. Okay. Ja.
Okay. Das ist ja mal ein schöner Lackmusstest, ne? Man fragt erstmal, ja und Kosten übernommen, so. Ah okay.
Bevor ich jetzt äh zur Urteilsverkündung mein Zug buche und das jetzt hier nicht unnötig.
Ach, wer denn gewonnen hat, dann fliege ich doch.
Nein, nein, also Inger, hier geht's ja nicht um Unsummen, das ist dann halt im Prinzip die die Arbeitszeit, die die Anwälte daran gesteckt haben.
Das sind ja dann das können ja dann doch schon durchaus mal äh signifikante Beträge sein, die man jetzt also jetzt nicht, dass man sagt, dass,
ist jetzt nur Porto, ne? Wobei allein das Papier, ich meine, warte, ich guck dir mal die das wo das ist jetzt auch kein besonders. Nein, ich meine wie viel Papier so eine Anwalt äh produzieren muss in in diesem.
Es ist ja auch nicht nur die Beschwerde, da äh innerhalb der Akten hast du dann auch noch äh da gibt's schon auch noch Schriftsätze zwischendurch. Und natürlich als der Schatz äh Tröaner Hack kam, kam dann neue Schrift daz,
Also war klar, man nimmt dir während eben das Beschwerdeverfahren läuft auch aktuelle Dinge auf,
und dann gibt's halt noch Schaffwechsel, die sind dann alle in den Nackten. Ich weiß das halt, weil weil man als Sachverständiger kriegt und dann natürlich auch liest. Man will ja wissen, was das was ist da die Diskussion.
Und die Beschwerdeführer haben eine Kostenerstattung bekommen,
Und wir schauen uns jetzt mal, weil das das Thema ist, was uns hier äh unter dem Vorzeichen der Netzpolitik am meisten interessiert. Wer natürlich weiter auf diese Staatströnergeschichte, ne? Das heißt, die den.
Na zwei Aspekte interessieren eigentlich, die die Staatsreuerne, aber eben auch der Kernbereich, bei der es glaube ich über den Trojaner hinaus spannend.
Und es im Namen des Volkes ergingen folgendes Urteil.
Na ja, das man kann net leider die Leitsätze sind halt verdammt kompliziert. Im Wesentlichen kann man sagen ja,
Also hat man, also man hat vorgelesen bekommen hat, ist das ja auch so im Wesentlichen ist es so, dass für sehr viele der Regelungen, also Wohnraumüberwachung für die
Online-Durchsuchung, dass sie eben für den Kernbereich nachbessern müssen. Das heißt, sie müssen Regelungen schaffen, wie sie sicherstellen, dass der Kernbereich eben geschützt bleibt. Hm, das sozusagen ziemlich ziemlich wesentliche Sache.
Das heißt, sie müssen in dem Gesetz schon definieren, wenn,
Online-Durchsuchung zum Einsatz kommt, müssen folgende Maßnahmen stattfinden, um den Kernbereich zu schützen. Was weiß ich, äh Vermessungen äh im so.
Und ähm der zweite, wichtige Aspekt, wenn man jetzt mal so aus Vermieterebene aus der Urteil guckt, ist eben die Verhältnismäßigkeit, wir sie haben für sehr viele Regelungen, technische Überwachungen, aber auch teilweise nicht technische Überwachung, also Observationen oder Spitze oder so. Ähm
die Verhältnismäßigkeit angemahnt. Sie wollen, also, dass das eben ähm äh verschiedentlich, also kann man jetzt nicht zusammenfassen, aber für verschiedene Paragraphen muss das verhältnismäßiger sein.
Verhältnismäßig heißt es soll im Paragraphen auch definiert sein ähm im Rahmen welcher Anschuldigung oder welche welches Verdachts einer Straftat dieses Ermittlungsinstruments zum Einsatz kommt.
Nein, nee, der Verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsatz ist so ein Jens, auch so ein, so ein, so ein juristischer Konstrukt, der besteht sozusagen immer aus drei Teilen, nämlich der Verhältnismäßigkeitsinnen, der Notwendigkeit und Erforderlichkeit und der anderen Gemessenheit
Also ähm heißt es kann unterschiedliche Aspekte haben.
Moment, die die Begriffe müssen wir glaube ich kurz erklären. Also äh notwendig und erforderlich, da hatte der Andre mir schon mal irgendwann Feedback gegeben äh zu einer Sendung, dass diese Begriffe im juristischen äh sehr,
Also wenn etwas muss erforderlich sein, heißt es geht wirklich nicht ohne.
Na und es gibt ja milderes Mittel.
Genau. Das genau erforderlich ist das mildeste Mittel, ohne dass es nicht geht.
Ähm ja und die äh,
Also man kann da glaube ich jetzt nicht so äh so allgemein sagen, für viele von den angegriffenen Normen wurde eben diese Verhältnismäßigkeit angemahnt
Und die hängt auch teilweise eben mit diesem Kernbrechschutz zusammen, dass sie eben
Pflichten dafür eingeführt werden müssen, dass man eben eine Prognose macht und wenn es gar nicht anders geht, das also was man tut und man trotzdem kernbereichsrelevante Daten, also höchstpersönlich jetzt aufzeichnet. Ähm,
Da geht's dann auch so um eine Frage, wer prüft das? Wie unabhängig muss die Stelle sein,
Beim Trojaner ist es etwa so, dass sie sagen, die Städte muss so unabhängig sein, dass es eben nicht innerhalb des BKAs geregelt werden kann, sondern dass sie ein eine andere Person hinzuziehen, ja. Also oder eben,
Ähm dann gibt's noch so die Fragen äh beim Trojaner von dem Löschlichten, ne? Weil hast du Protokollierung
dieser Truanisierung und wie lange müssen die aufgehoben werden? Das war verfassungswidrig, weil die nur so kurz waren. Wann hast du diese Frage der Zweckänderung? Was wird ein Trojaner wird aufgezeichnet? Ja, wer darf denn das weiter nutzen?
unter welchen Bedingungen und da haben wir so eine interessante hypothetische Datenneuerhebung, ist ein interessanter Begriff. Design nämlich die sozusagen, sie orientieren sich da dran. Ähm,
Ja, was so zu sagen, die die Schwere des Eingriffs ist und die Hypothetische Datenneuerhebung wird dann quasi angenommen, wenn man die,
Zweck äh Änderung vornimmt. Also Daten für was ganz anderes benutzen will. Ihr könnt also haben wir jetzt neue Begriffe erfunden.
Also die das heißt, die weiß nicht Verdächtigen dich äh des Mordes. Äh troanisieren deinen Computer und werden darauf werden da in im Laufe dessen darauf aufmerksam, dass du äh ich finde Sharing machst.
Na, jetzt ist jetzt eine der geringe aber nimmer eine andere als Betrug oder so, also eine ja. Und äh.
Dann ist die Frage, dürfen sie diese, die dadurch äh äh ermittelten Beweismittel in dem in dem anderen Ermittlungsverfahren nutzen oder dürfen sie aufgrund derer ein Ermittlungsverfahren eröffnen? Und dürfen sie oder nicht?
Na äh diese diese hypothetische Daten äh neue Erhebung,
bezieht sich halt darauf, dass das, was sie dir vorwerfen von ähnlichem Gewicht sein muss. Das ist sozusagen, was würde dieser Begriff ungefähr aussagen? Äh haben sie ein längerer Stück hier drin. Ich muss auch erzählen, wie er Juristen werden bestimmt wieder sagen, ich erkläre das nicht korrekt. Ich versuche ja nun verständlich zu mach.
Das seien die immer.
Das sagen die immer und dann können sie es nicht besser. Also.
Aber da geht's natürlich auch teilweise um die Übermittlung ins Ausland, wohin interessanter Punkt ist auch, wo ja die Frage ist, äh nach Menschenrechten, wenn man ins Ausland überträgt, aber auch wenn man Daten holt, da hat sich Gerhard Baum auch besonders drüber gefreut, dass eben,
sehr klar drinsteht, dass man eben auch die Menschenrechte beachten muss, wenn Mandaten weitergibt oder also an ausländische äh Behörden und so weiter und auch entgegennimmt.
klar. Dann geht's aber auch um Berichtspflichten. BKA hat mit dem Urteil eine Berichtspflicht reingedrückt bekommen.
Darf ich noch ganz kurz anfangen? Du hattest gerade gesagt, die Speicherfristen für die durch Trojaner erlangten Daten waren zu kurz.
Die Löschprotokolle. Denn sie müssen dir auch wieder von deinem Gebütter entfernen und du sollst natürlich also überhaupt die Protokollierung. Du kannst sollst,
für den Beschuldigten aufheben, dass er nachvollziehen kann, wann ist denn das Ding gelöscht worden? Also die Löschbrotkolle.
Okay. Die Daten, die sie erlangen, die werden solange aufbewahrt, wie Beweismittel aufbewahrt werden müssen.
Sind aber bereits äh Fristen im ähm BKA-Gesetz und da gibt's auch schon Regelungen für die Benachrichtigungspflicht und so. Da haben sie aber teilweise für unterschiedliche Paragraphen
auch neue Regeln entworfen, also wie äh wie das mit der Benachrichtigung sein soll. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht auswendig für die einzelnen Paragra.
Man bekommt eine Benachrichtigung.
Ja, gibt Benachrichtigungspflichten, genau.
Macht bitte immer alle schön eure Backups und wenn.
Die Benachrichtigung die sind ja nur in vielen Gesetzen immer eine schwierige Sache, denn solange sie ermitteln brauchen sie sowieso nicht benachrichtigen. Ja. Benachrichtigten Ende. Es gibt auch Ausnahmen.
Nachrichten dann am Ende in den seltensten Fällen, ja. Aber wenn man Pick-up.
Er die sind schon wichtig, weil für diese Fälle, denn hier sie leiten ja den Terrorismus schon, auch aus dem hundertneunundzwanzig A direkt ab. Also hat ganz wenig Gerichtsverfahren. Und die Tatsache, dass es wenig Gerichtsverfahren gibt, heißt,
wenig nachgelagerte rechtliche Prüfung,
Insofern ist die Benachrichtigung schon von hoher Wichtigkeit auch, diese Berichtspflicht, die sie dem BKA jetzt reindrücken. Sie sagen auch, wir wollen diese Berichtspflicht, damit die Öffentlichkeit und das Parlament überhaupt nachvollziehen kann, ob hier auch sozusagen rechtskonform gehandelt wird.
Das gilt für Online-Durchsuchung und Quellen TKÜ gleichermaßen, was.
Ja aber auch noch für andere, also Wohnraumüberwachung und so,
also sie müssen halt ja und der solle übrigens auch hinreichend gehaltvoll sein, inhaltlich. Der Bericht des BKA.
Das ist das ist wahrscheinlich die größte Hürde.
Fand ich sehr interessant, dass sie also sagen, daraus soll man auch was ablesen können, um eben klar zu machen, ob sie das auch rechtmäßig anwenden. Also ich will nicht immer ähm,
Ich glaube auch schon, dass solche Behörden wie die BKA natürlich ein Interesse daran haben müssen, dass sie transparent machen, wie sie im Nachhinein, wie sie dann umgegangen sind. Meine ihr Ruf ist äh gerade in den hundertneunundsiebzig A Fällen nicht besonders gut.
so, das liegt natürlich
einfach an den Fällen, wie sie gelaufen sind. Und überhaupt an der Tatsache, dass wir immer nur unter fünf Prozent überhaupt von Fällen haben, die jemals zu einem Gerichtsverfahren kommen, bei diesem Terrorismusvorwürf.
Klar, das ist auch.
Genau und insofern kann die Behörde eigentlich auch nun Interesse haben, das über diese Berichtspflicht.
Dass sie ihn, dass sie, wenn sie das Ding schon als Beweismittel dann irgendwann vielleicht mal tatsächlich vor Gericht bringen, dass ihnen das dann nicht noch abgesichert wird, ne.
Na ja und dann ist halt, wird dann uns natürlich besonders interessiert halt, wir haben dieser Trojaner
natürlich 'ne Frage und hier war ja erstmal die Unterscheidung zwischen Qualität Öl natürlich für uns wichtig und leider ist es tatsächlich so, dass sie diese Unterscheidung eher noch unterm Mord haben,
Also,
Sie sagen tatsächlich das Grundrecht auf Gewährleistung der Vertraulichkeit und Integrität von Informationstechnik System geht nicht explizit nicht für die Quellen TKÜ, sondern hier ist das Telekommunikationsgeheimnis nach Artikel zehn. Einschlägig.
Das war genau der juristische Hakenschlag, den den eigentlich diese Quellen TKÜ ausgemacht hat, ne. Ähm.
Sie sagen halt letztlich anders als in dem alten Urteil, wo die Infiltration des Rechners denkt, entscheidende Punkt war, dass sie einfach annehmen, sie sagen, ist ja nicht unser Problem, ob sie technisch hinkriegen,
Wir sagen einfach, dieser Trojaner darf nur laufende Kommunikation abhören, damit ist es kein Madi-Hemd. Also Telekommunikationsgeheimnis und das ist ja auf einer Weise durchlöchert, ist ja schon lächerlich. Also seit wir jetzt sozusagen digitale Kommunikation haben ist, sie sind äh Vermählegeheimt ist ein Witz.
Also wegen sehr, also ich meine, es wird ja auch massenhaft getan. Ähm,
Aber sie nehmen vor allen Dingen an, dass man das technisch könnte. Und man muss sich ja klar machen, dass äh,
Zwischen laufender Kommunikation und nicht ist ein Handgriff und zwar ein Tabwechsel äh wenn sie etwa einen Screencast oder Screenshots von meinem Webmailer machen, dann ist es,
eine Handbewegung und ich bin in einem anderen Tab. Und da läuft mein Yuporen, was weiß ich, was das mal läuft. Mein mein Craft von Nutzbander für heute, ne? Wenn man also für,
Kybanetischen Sex.
Was bei dir so läuft.
Also ist klar und also dann hat man natürlich Problematik, hat man natürlich, finde ich auch sehr stark bei der TKÖ, also wenn du was in dein Forum oder in einen Chat tippst oder ein Skype oder nicht abschickst, dann wird's nie Kommunikation
sondern es sind entäußerte Gedanken von dir selbst, die die niemals zur Kommunikation werden. Und diese Problematik haben sie so nicht aufgegriffen,
die müssten sie aber letztlich äh natürlich auch für andere äh Telekommunikationen aufgreifen. Aber ich finde, äh ich finde es äh,
ich bin nicht zufrieden mit diesem Bereich, überhaupt nicht. Sie sagen natürlich okay, wenn sie das technisch nicht können, nur Telekommunikation abhören, dann laufen sie ins Leere. Das steht auch so, dann läuft der Paragraph leer. Aber,
Erinnert ihr nichts daran, dass sie bestimmte Problematiken nicht aufgreifen, ja? Und überhaupt übrigens auch nicht die Problematik der ganzen Schwarzmärkte. Wo kriegen die denn dieses Wirkung her, die sie da ausnutzen und so?
der ist, ich finde, die hängt deutlich mehr dran, aber ich glaube, aufgrund der Fülle von Rechtsproblemen äh die sich dem Staatsrainer ja auch nicht mehr so intensiv gewidmet.
Das heißt, sie, also ein ein generelles Urteil darüber, dass man jetzt das,
das Grund das Grundrecht auf Wahrung, äh Gewährleistung der Intivität auch so verstehen kann, dass der Staat eben einfach zu sagen hat, wenn wir irgendwo von irgendeiner Sicherheitslücke wissen, dann ist es unsere,
Ist es das Grundrecht unserer Bürger, dass wir sie darüber in Kenntnis setzen und für ein äh zumindestens für ein Bekanntwerden, wenn nicht sogar oft für einschließende Sicherheitslücke äh Sorge tragen? Diese.
Bin, äh, ist ja auch diese BSE-Problematik noch dabei, ja? Wir haben halt ein Amt, hat sich eigentlich um
die Sicherheit, also IT-Sicherheit von Bürgern, Unternehmen kümmern soll und war nachweislich beteiligt am Staatstreuaner. Also es ist ein ehender Spagat, aber all diese Sachen sind nicht wirklich.
Gar nichts zu gesagt. Das hätte.
Es ist interessant deshalb, weil wir natürlich, wir wissen ja viel mehr über diesen Schwarzmarkt Salznorden,
Wir wissen überhaupt mehr über die Praxis und übrigens auch über automatisierte Infetrationen. Ich bin gar nicht mehr sicher, ob wenn die über äh sozusagen diese Inflatration oder generell,
verdeckte äh heimliche, verdeckte technische Ermittlungen sozusagen reden. Ob man dann nur über einen Zufall reden muss. Wir wissen ja, aus den Snowen Veröffentlichungen sind auch sehr wohl äh automatisierte Verfahren bei schon gibt, der.
Das wussten wir sowas im Leistungskatal Katalog von Gamma schon vorher. Also, dass sie diese Dinger, die ins Regal gestellt, ne, ins Rect mit reingestellt werden und Softwareupdates kaputt äh zerstören oder so, äh da bereithalten.
Der ist der ganze Spagat zwischen wo Krieg die Sicherheitslücken her, wie äh welchen Markt bediene ich da eigentlich? Da ist meine Pflicht nicht eigentlich. Äh eine ganz andere auch im Sinne einer kritischen Infrastruktur und so weiter. Und eine zweite Problematik ist überhaupt nicht erwähnt
ja du kannst mit einem Trojanerleb und Leben von Mensch gefährden
Nämlich, wenn Informationstechnische System eins ist, wo ein Mensch drinsitzt oder ein Medizinalgerät. Äh auch wenn du nicht willst, also wir wissen ja auch, es kann ja auch handwerklicher Fehler sein. Ist überhaupt nicht adressiert,
Also ich finde, die sind halt Bereiche, um die sie sich letztlich äh dann auch nicht kümmern. Also gut, wie gesagt, das war ein klare Touch an äh sehr vielen Problemen.
Was ja nichts ändert. Ich meine nur, weil man, weil man viele in ein Gesetz schreibt, kann es ja nicht sein. Man schreibt da jetzt so viel rein, äh dass man den ein oder anderen Quatsch ähm.
Na ja, ich denke mal, also der Berichterstatter äh Richter Masing in dem Fall, der wird vielleicht nach fünf Jahren jetzt vielleicht auch mal die Chance voll gehabt haben von diesem BKA-Gesetz, ja.
Was bedeutet denn das jetzt eigentlich konkret für den schon erwähnten neuen Trojaner, der jetzt ja so toll äh äh und Gesetzeskonform daherkommt.
Na ja, das Erste ist, wenn das ein Quellen dicke Ütrojaner ist, was er ja zu sein scheint für Hundos, müssen sie halt technisch,
Realisieren, dass er nur laufende Kommunikationsvorgänge abhören kann. Ansonsten ist es eine Online-Durchsuchung und damit sehr viel höhere Hürden. Technisch. Also im Sinne von rechtlicher rechtlichen Hürden.
Technisch bei Skype geht das, ja,
Also da das so haben ja schon immer diese Trojaner Skype Module und auch irgendwie Skype Call Recorder und solche Sachen funktioniert und wenn ich mich nicht täusche war das doch bei dem Digitals Trojaner auch so
dass du quasi ein ein Skype-Plugin wirst, was äh in dem Moment, wo ein Telefonat anfängt,
ich glaube als Audiodevice oder sowas das ganze Ding nochmal auf 'ne Datei wegschreibt, ne? Das heißt also,
kriegt man bei Skype dieser dieser einen Anforderung äh nur Kommunikation aufzeichnen, der wird man im Falle von Skype vermutlich gerecht,
Wäre jetzt so mein.
Na, mehrere Sachen dazu. Das eine ist, du wirst ja, das kann ja also so eine Maßnahme, der für maximal drei Monate
Also das ist ja eine dauerhafte Infetration. Musste natürlich auch für einige sorgen mit dem Betreuer. Weißt du, weißt du selber, also ich meine, er muss halt gucken, dass er Detektionsmechanismen auf dem Rechner umgeht
Du musst den, du wirst ihm möglicherweise Befehle senden müssen. Äh und da entsteht natürlich Problematiken. Äh das eine ist äh wie ist das mit dem Nachladen,
reagieren musst auf den Nutzer, weil er vielleicht sich eine neue Version holt oder so. So, in der Art. Ähm,
Was die Problematik ist natürlich auch bei Skype, äh jemand etwas tippen kann und nicht abschick,
Die Kommunikation wird oder so, ja, kann ja natürlich passieren. Äh du hast die Problematik mit dem höchstpersönlichen ja auch,
also wie Männer gut aufgezeichnet Gespräch waren oder Quellen TKÜ, also die vorhin erwähnte Cybersex sozusagen. Er war eine Qualität, die hast du natürlich trotzdem.
wie bei jeder Kommunikation kann er ja ganz natürlich, also kannst du ja ein Telefon auch nehmen. Hm. Ja, so einfach finde ich, ist es nicht zu sagen, ja.
Ich habe gesagt, diese eine technische Anforderung, dass der die Nachladen ist, dann,
Nachladen ist ist natürlich so ein Problem, du kannst den Trojaner äh nicht guten Gewissens ohne Nachladefunktion bauen,
wenn der es könnte ja auch sein, dass du
versehentlich einen schlech kaputten, einen nicht funktionsfähigen einen nicht äh gesetzmäßigen oder sonst was da hochlädst, du brauchst diese Funktion zum Update, allein schon, wie du gerade sagst, Skypeupdate, Betriebssystem, Update oder sowas du willst
nachladen können.
Na ja auch für die Entfernung nicht wahr? Also.
Genau und du musst ihn ja auch entfernen können, das heißt in in dem Moment du du nimmst einen Eingriff in die Intimität vor, indem du ihn dahin bringst und du musst dann irgendwie auch dafür sorgen, dass der, dass er entfernt wird.
Du willst natürlich auch nichts kaputt machen, äh im Sinne von irgendwie funktionsunfähig oder sowas. Also und natürlich wirst du nicht deliktiert werden.
Genau, in dem das ist, denke ich, wahrscheinlich das, wo die sich am meisten Sorgen machen, wenn der jetzt irgendwen, wenn der detektiert wird und auf einmal die Signaturen in irgendwelchen Virenscannern sind,
Dann willst du auf den Knopf drücken und deinen nächsten äh Deploin, ne? Also einfach gucken, dass der nicht mehr detektiert wird. Also macht man das halt.
Na ja, die Frage ist, wie prüfst du das? Also, wer hat Einblick äh A in die Dokumentation, die ja sozusagen auf dieser Leistungsbeschreibung beruht, darf jemand den Quellcode sehen? Und wenn ja, wer.
Sowas ist da nicht geregelt. Ich meine, das wäre äh haben sie da nicht auch, warum äh verlangen sie da eine Regelung zu oder sagen sie da.
Na, es gibt Dokumentationspflichten und eben auch zum Beispiel für den für das Löschen und so. Natürlich, aber es wird,
Schon noch was anderes, ob jemand den Quergut sehen kann. Äh uns ist ja letztlich auch nicht, also im Internet ist halt auch nicht eine sollte man immer sehen bei dieser Treuanisierung, dass eben keiner Momentaufnahme, sondern du hast immer eine Zeitspanne,
und Button Unterschied macht in der Bewertung auch.
Online-Durchsuchung.
Also da haben sie insbesondere den den auch den Kernbereich Schutz äh abgestellt, aber da gibt's noch so einen kleinen Aspekt ähm sie, sie hatten geschrieben,
das äh nur allein, also das Wort allein war da sehr wichtig. Ähm wenn es nur allein höchstpersönlich geht, dann
solle man eben ähm nicht abhören können. Und da hat Gerichte sehr klargestellt, er hat gesagt, also äh teste aber jetzt noch nicht, äh dass wenn sich alltägliche und höchstpersönlich jetzt mischt, dass man das nicht mit beachten muss,
Ja, also daher, also die haben da so ein bisschen bisschen klargestellt und man muss halt auch eine äh Prognose machen, ja.
Da sind wir auch wieder bei dem Punkt, den ich gerade ansprechen wollte. Sie haben diese Kontrolle. Ja, was wird jetzt was,
So, Trojaner hat gesammelt, äh hat nach Hause gefunkt, jetzt gibt's da einen Haufen ähm Gesprächsprotokoll, vielleicht sogar Dateien, wenn sie Online-Durchsuchung ist und dann wurde vorgeschrieben, es soll eine unabhängige Stelle sein
dann dieses Material sichtet, ähm haben die da Ideen, Vorschriften.
Es ist, sie sind sogar sehr klar, weil sie sagen, also äh dieser BKA-Datenschutzbeauftragter darf es nicht sein. Also
unabhängig vom BKA, haben sie schon sehr, haben sie sehr klar gemacht. Also für ihn ist schon wichtig, dass äh es sind ja letztlich auch äh Beschuldigtenrechte
dass man eben also nicht nur, sondern nicht nur Beschuldigtenrechte, aber eben, dass man die Möglichkeit hat, eben,
auch eine Sünde, ja wie so eine Blickkette zu haben. Ähm ja.
Welche Institutionen käme einem da in den Sinn? Andrea Vossof hat keine Zeit. Also sieht man diese nie irgendwo, die hatte, also die ist einfach sehr, sehr beschäftigt.
Die ach bist du wieder gemein, aber möglicherweise haben wir irgendwann mal jemanden im Amt, der da doch ausfällt, könnte doch sein in Zukunft.
Also wer wäre das jetzt die politische I.
Man könnte sich überlegen, ob das Wort der Bundeswehr könnte natürlich auch eine andere Behörde sein, die technisch kompetent ist.
Stück davon haben wir eigentlich genug, gell.
Also unabhängig stehen die halt so da, also eine Stelle, unabhängig vom BKA. Äh sozusagen der Punkt, den sie machen wollen.
Dann natürlich hoffentlich so groß, dass man nicht einzelne davon äh identifiziert oder unter Druck setzen kann oder so, ne? Aber das hast ja.
Ja, aber wir reden jetzt mit der Unterdurchsuchung. Das wird ein seltener Fall sein. Äh sie haben sie, ja, nein, doch, die Hürden sind einfach verdammt hoch. Aber ich meine, sie sie öffnen ja halt auch die gesamte Platte und damit denken, dein Gehirn, dein dein, dein.
Bei der bei der TKÜ gilt dieser Anspruch nicht. Weil sie sagen, wir folgen der Argumentation, das ist eine Kommunikationsüberwachung und wenn ihr eine äh Kommunikationsüberwachung macht, dann müsst ihr euch auch sonst nicht.
Auch bei auch bei der Telekommunikationsüberwachung ist der Kerl später Kernbereich eine Rolle. Aber sie müssen.
Unabhängige.
Nee und also du musst dir halt nicht diesen Aufwand machen wie wir eben bei einer Wohnungsverwandung oder wie bei wie bei der Unterdurchsuchung.
Ähm entstehen dadurch auch äh Fragen für die Beschlagnahme von Speichermedien.
Nähelt ist diesmal leider nicht erwähnt im eigenen Hotel war war ja klar, dass sie also auch die Beschlagnahme auf Festplatten äh mit angesprochen haben. Es hat hier keine Rolle gespielt,
leider nicht. Aber wie gesagt, äh der Trojaner ist eben, ob es ein Aspekt ist, sind zwei Paragraphen von sehr, sehr vielen. Also zwanzig KMH, zwanzig L.
Die äh Absätze zweihundertsiebenundzwanzig und.
Habe ich mir nicht gemerkt, weiß ich nicht.
Online gesehen, du hast glaube ich keine Absetznummerierung in der.
Doch doch sind Juristen, die haben ja, ja, genau, also der.
Zwei siebenundzwanzig oder zwei siebzehn oder sowas war da.
Äh ich bin jetzt gar nicht sicher, es fängt so mit bei zwo eins drei an. Ey, wie kann man, also ist jetzt dumm, mit dem Papier zu blättern, wo man das online machen könnte. Ich habe jetzt eigentlich nur mitgebracht, weil weiß ich auch nicht. Also.
Um anzugeben, wie viel Papier das ist. Doppelseitig bedruckt, beidseitig bedruckt, äh ein guter Zentimeter.
Ja, es ist äh also wobei es jetzt auch also nicht zu klein bedruckt, also im Grundsatz,
kann man eine Untersuchung ähm verfassungskonform machen und,
Sie haben ein Oregien dafür gemacht, die im BKA gesetzt hat, teilweise nicht stehen, aber im Grundsatz sagen sie, wir lassen sozusagen diese Art der Infetration zu.
Und die Quellen TKÜ auch und das sogar zu, sagen wir mal sehr viel lascheren Voraussetzungen, als wir die.
Also da geht halt dieses Grundrecht der Gewährleistung kontaktiert. Also nicht.
Die Argumentation oder ich frage jetzt mal deine Argumentation wäre eigentlich schon gewesen, dass im Prinzip die Trennung oder das wäre echt meine Argumentation wäre. Eine Trennung zwischen äh Quellen TKÜ und ähm,
Online-Durchsuchung ähm ist eigentlich nicht haltbar, nicht technisch verargumentier und haltbar.
Ja, weil ich eigentlich äh würde das auch so sagen, einfach weil ich glaube, dass das im ersten Urteil postulierte ähm grundsätzliche Dinge mit der Infetration der Punkt ist. Du machst halt ein System auf, musst du
Und damit hast du natürlich einige Probleme, die du dir mit ranziehst. Und du musst auch immer diese Form äh des Nachladens haben, ansonsten ja. Also macht sich wirklich Sinn.
und die der Rattenschwanz an Problemen, den wir noch hatten, ja. Da könnten Dritte, ja, du hast den Schwarzwald kommt noch dazu, aber die Infotationen war der entscheidende Schritt äh in dem alten Urteil und die Kerte dafür korrekt zu sagen,
du also das Grundlage ist ja gerade die Gewährleistung der ja Vertraulichkeit Integrität.
Das heißt du lötest eine, du lötest eine Wanze in ein Telefon, ähm dann kannst du mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit sagen, dass diese Wanze,
Eine Funktion hat, sie ist ein Mikrofon und ähm diese Funktionalität kann man irgendwie,
Gewährleisten, aber das ist eben der Unterschied zwischen einer Hardware und einer Software
Ähm, dass die Software eben grundsätzlich vor allem, wenn sie schon Kommunikation abhören kann, einfach auf dem System, mit einem mit einer Berechtigung läuft, die ist eher im Prinzip auch alles andere ermöglicht, weil der Computer,
als allerletztes äh zu unterscheiden weiß, äh was eine Funktion ist, die jetzt gerade ausführen soll oder nicht
die im Interesse seines Nutzers ist oder nicht und ob eine, ob ein Datum, eine Kommunikation, ein Bild, eine Datei, wenn nun Kernbereich ist oder nicht.
Ja, na ja, diese, diese semantische Unterscheidung kann natürlich äh eher ein Computer, zumindest derzeit, nicht, nicht wirklich machen. Aber ist noch gar nicht mehr der Punkt, also die die du musst halt bestimmte privilegierte Rechte bekommen
um er und das ist halt letztlich deswegen macht für mich diese Unterscheidung aus technischer Sicht überhaupt wenig Sinn. Da gibt keinen Sinn.
Ähm ich finde halt eigentlich, dass man so eine Technik unbedingt am heutigen Istzustand bewerten muss, sondern eben, so wie das andere Urteil auch getan hat, an der Entwicklung, wo sie immer hingeht. Äh deswegen haben die nie über Computer gesprochen, sondern über Informationstechnische Systeme.
Das beste Beispiel ist, du machst ein Gesetz zur Kommunikations äh zur Telekommunikationsüberwachung und ein paar Jahrzehnte später äh schreiben die Leute auf einmal Software und sagen Quellen TKÖ, ne? Also das ist ja genau so ein ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass was für Folgen so ein Gesetz haben kann
in Jahren oder Jahrzehnten, wenn es im neuen Licht interpretiert wird.
Also insofern äh,
War schon irgendwie froher Tag und die meisten waren auch sehr zufrieden inklusive mir selbst, aber natürlich sind da Details bei, die für mich äh richtig halte. Ich glaube, dass dieser Art der staatlichen Inflation grundsätzlich falsch ist
Aus verschiedenen Gründen, auch aus technischen, aber nicht nur. Also ich glaube, auch so im Sinne einer sinnvollen IT-Sicherheit in Zukunft ist das der falsche Weg.
Natürlich hat man die Problematik wie dann äh mal vorgebracht wird, dass es Aspekte geben wird, die man nicht abhören kann. Für akzeptabel, denn ähm analogen leben, ja
konnte man auch nie eine Form man konnte nie jeden,
Kommunikationsvorgang mithören, nicht mal mit größtem Aufwand und ich halte das für äh vertretbar,
dass es eben so ist. Also zumal in einem Land, wo wir einfach sehr viele Straftaten aufklären. Die Quote ist ja sehr hoch. Äh ich denke, dass
Verschlüsselung von Kommunikation, insbesondere aber Hauptverschlüsselung ist ein Weg,
wie wir mit den mit den Geräten, die uns umgeben werden, mit denen wir von denen wir abhängig werden wie Hölle ähm umgehen können, dass man
Also ich glaube, das ist ein ganz zentraler Punkt, soweit was wir heute im Manalogen kennen überhaupt in die Praxis umzusetzen, ja. Und ich denke,
Es ist der falsche Weg. Äh ich.
Könnte auch teuer werden für die Behörden und irgendwann lassen sich's sein. Ich lese gerade, dass äh koportiert wird, dass das FBI für diesen,
einmaligen Zugriff auf das äh besagte iPhone die eins Komma drei vier Millionen US Dollar abgedrückt hat.
Na die Özils haben ja auch eine Sommer. Also die bezahlen alleine im Lizenzgebühren im Jahr vierhundertfünfzigtausend Euro,
Also nur Lizenzgebühren. Hm, die eben auch gerade eine Debatte in Österreich darum,
da haben sie noch so eine schöne Regelung, die der so bei uns nicht gibt, die dürfen nämlich auch in eine Wohnung rennen, um die den zu einzupflanzen. Schönen Tag auch.
Äh also äh wobei die Debatte, also ist ein Entwurf, da gibt's natürlich auch noch Streitraum.
Tja, aber beim Geld wird's ja dann meistens sehr konkret, was politische Entscheidungen betrifft so.
So, sie haben in Deutschland auch einen kommerziellen äh äh Trojaner beim BK.
Ich dachte sie haben doch.
Als Ausfalllösung sozusagen. Wenn was wenn der eigene nicht so richtig hinaut. Äh.
Schaukuck. Das sind die hunderttausend Euro, die an Gama gegangen sind oder was.
Ne, sie, nee, sie haben ja von verschiedenen kommerziellen äh äh Anbietern getestet. Das waren so eine davor haben sie auch hohe Summen bezahlt, aber nicht wann der Test,
Wir wissen ja auch nicht warum diese Tests nicht fortgeführt wurden. Wie man hat irgendwie nicht rechtskonform, aber man weiß ja nicht, äh genauere da ist man ja nicht warum die zu sagen mit denen nicht ins Geschäft kam.
Ja oder der Test war beendet dadurch, dass sie mit denen ins Geschäft gekommen sind, ne? Das.
Nee, nee, also bei einigen weiß man ja, dass sie äh sie nicht mit denen Geschäfte kommen sind. Also bei Elaman zum Beispiel,
Ja. Da weiß man ja, dass also da kam es nicht zu einem aber warum? Also die wissen natürlich auch nicht welche Version, ja? Aber zumindest bei einem weiß man das. Also.
Wer ist noch auf dem Markt Hacking Team? Ähm.
Na da haben sie sich auf jeden Fall ausweislich der der E-Mails, die da gelegt sind, äh da gab es auf jeden Fall Kontakte auch so zum wahrscheinlich Funktionsumfang rauskriegen. Ja hm, aber was haben wir denn noch? Also,
es gibt noch diese eine, na jetzt fällt mir gerade der Name nicht ein. Ähm,
wissen wir auch, dass mit denen äh Testversion abgemacht haben, die heißen, ach, komme ich jetzt grad nicht drauf. Das ist der Nachteil, wenn man beim Podcast keinen Rechner hat.
Ich bin auf weit weg, weil ich weiß, wie sehr du das magst.
Ja, ich finde, ich finde das Gespräch jetzt auf der anderen Seite, wenn man zwischendurch wir gucken mal, der Tim gerade an, als wenn man zwischendurch äh nein, nein, ist okay.
Was soll ich denn? Wo soll ich was recherchieren? Ich bin ganz für euch da.
Liste der Produzenten von Staatstrojanern.
Also wir wir halten mal fest, das ist mittlerweile natürlich eine ganze Reihe von Anbietern, gibt auch äh über Deutschland hinaus, aber ich glaube, dass sie eher sich natürlich in Deutschland umgesehen haben.
Ich widme mich, würde ja dann nochmal interessieren, gab's irgendetwas dazu? Also,
Viele der Trojaner äh Azur Service Leistung äh die haben ja sowas wie dass sie dass der Command Control Server eben auch,
von von der Firma, die den Trojaner bereitstellt, unterhalten wird. Das heißt du, ja,
gehacking asse Service, ne? Das heißt, die haben auch die, die Infrastruktur, die updaten denen und du hast halt ein Backend für den Zugriff. Gab's da irgendwelche, ähm, gab's da Urteile zu? Oder gab's da äh Meinungen zu? Weil man geht ja so davon aus, dass ähm der Staat hackt jetzt äh seine
Feinde oder seine Gegner. Ähm,
Sehr häufig sieht man ja dann eben etwas andere Infrastrukturen, wo eben äh mehr oder weniger eine Firma,
beauftragt wird eine ein Ziel zu hacken und die es ein,
einen einzelnen oder einige wenige Command and Control-Server gibt, wo diese Trojaner dann hin berichten und die Kunden in dem Fall die Strafverfolgungsbehörden oder die anderen Kriminellen, die sich bei denen Dienstleistungen einkaufen, äh loggen sich dann da ein, gibt's da zufällig in dem Urteil irgendeine
'ne Maßgabe zu, dass sowas nicht.
Unser Forderung oder ist natürlich auch schon lange das sozusagen äh der Quellcode in seiner Zeit auch offen gelegt werden muss, zumindest nachgelagert und so, aber natürlich äh ist das nicht Teil nee, leider nicht, also ähm,
Ich äh hielte das für sehr wichtig, zum Beispiel auch für die Richtertierprüfung dann.
Oder das Speichern der Dateien auf äh auch nur interem Speichern, auf Infrastruktur, die nicht äh.
Ich kann dir das mal kurz sagen, was denn derzeit zu sagen, das Gesetz ist, nämlich, wird man sozusagen protokollieren muss, nämlich die Bezeichnung des technischen Mittels, den Zeitpunkt seines Einsatzes. Die Angaben zur Identifizierung des Informationstechnischen Systems,
und die daran,
die flüchtigen Veränderungen, die man daran vorgenommen hat, die Angaben, äh die die Feststellung der erhobenen Daten ermöglichen und die Organisation zur Einheit der BKA die Maßnahme vornimmt. Da ist also natürlich von äh vom Quellkot und so keine Rede,
Ja.
Irgendwie was was man da nehmt, da schreibt man dann hin äh Staatsrainer Staatsrat. Was haben wir hier benutzt? Quälticatrojaner oder so, ne? Da würde man sich ja schon irgendwie wünschen, dass die wenigsten
wenigstens dokumentieren, welches Bein sich zu welchem Zeitpunkt da befunden hat, sei es nur mit einer eigenen Cashfunktion, also also dass man wenigstens,
im Zweifelsfall nachweisen kann, was man da hatte, ne. Also das ist ja dann in,
Die können sich natürlich auch gleichzeitig denken, wie schnell ihnen äh wenn sie da irgendeine Lücke drin haben, wie schnell irgendein Anwalt ihnen sie da auf äh Rausgabe fax.
Na ja, das ist natürlich auch die Wiederverwendbarkeit. Also ich meine, die werden den Quellkurt nicht für eine einzige Person schreiben. Äh also.
Teuer, teuer wird für sie ja ohnehin nur der Quellentäger Trojaner. Für alles andere, wenn du keine ähm
technischen Vorgaben über die Limitation deines Einsatzmittelhass, dann nimmst du ja lieber,
Trojaner von der Stange, äh irgendwie wie,
jemand im Bundestag gemacht hat, denn die haben ja keinen Staatstroanad dahin geschickt, sondern die haben halt äh mit Mimicats einfach sich eingebaut, ja? Also das äh damit du eben im Falle der,
ne? Also
du hast ja, wenn du jetzt auf deinem Computer eine Trojanerinfektion feststellst oder eine Unregelmäßigkeit und du stellst fest, dass diese Unregelmäßigkeit äh Skype betrifft, dann kannst du dir ungefähr denken, äh wo lang der Hase läuft, wenn du ähm,
Eine allgemeine trojane Infektion feststellt, dann bleibt für dich immer alles offen zwischen, du bist Teil eines riesigen Boardnetz äh oder was weiß ich,
Der Russe ist gekommen oder oder der Armi, ne? Also das heißt da darfst du ja Ermittlungsstrategisch äh,
viel bessere Möglichkeiten, zumindest im Falle der Entdeckung, erstens die Kosten gering zu halten, weil du dir einfach den nächsten äh Trojaner baust äh und zweitens im Falle der Entdeckung eben auch keinerlei Anhaltspunkte für zu
dass es sich um einen Staatsrealer handelt.
Also du hast im Prinzip die Wesenpunkte, ja, wenn du also,
natürlich kann trotzdem also man muss sich einfach vorstellen, wir reden jetzt immer sehr viel über äh Minusbetriebssysteme, weil einfach ähm auch seitens des BKA, als wenn das Trojaner dargestellt wurde, aber kann natürlich auch erheblich teurer werden für, sage ich mal, etwas,
seltenere Systeme, aber wenn ein Verdächtiger, ich sage mal, Lubunto benutzt, ja,
habe ich viel mir gerade einen Offscore-Betriebssystem an. Also dann wird's wird schon, ja, ich wollte jetzt gar nicht von B-Telefone raus, aber auch da äh.
Mobiltelefone wird, also.
Hey oder benutzte Sale, ist also einfach Randgruppen, oh, habe ich Randgruppen, wo ihr sagt, ja.
Subgraf, jetzt müssen wir aber die Liste aufmachen.
Ich habe Debby angesagt.
Open BSC.
Äh Kubundup. Äh äh äh Cent US.
Slackware.
Äh äh wer hat mir Schnai OS?
Suiano Mott.
Siano Genmot, ha, du hast verloren.
Ja, wer sich wer richtig Plan hat, der kompliziert sich sein Betriebssystem ja sowieso selber und dann.
Ach du Mainz Fefi kriegt nie einen äh kriegt nie einen Staatsröhrne.
Nee, aber das haben wir, mag andere Gründe haben.
Das mag andere Grüne haben.
Wollen wir hoffen, dass er bis hierher bis hierher nicht mitgehört.
Und mach mal ein Fazit, Lenus.
Das Fazit musst du äh machen. Also was mich vielleicht könntest du ja sagen, was hat sich, hat sich jetzt für die wie ist jetzt die Prognose, wie also passieren wird, dem müssen wir BKA-Gesetz nachbessern.
Ja und sie haben eine sehr lange Frist, bis äh zu sagen Juno zweitausendachtzehn, verdammt lang und nicht alle Paragraphen sind sofort nicht. Einige dürfen weiter gelten bis zu dieser Frist.
Und das gilt für die ähm für die äh Infiltations äh Paragraphen.
Äh die können weiter gelten,
Allerdings haben sie äh einzelne Beschränkungen, also etwa bei dem Kernbreischutz äh vorgegeben. Also sie, sie können, sie haben immer zwei Möglichkeiten zu sagen, entweder nicht dich,
oder eben nicht, aber für den Fall, dass es nicht sofort wichtig ist, äh zwar beanstandet wird, aber nicht nicht die ist, können sie Beschränkungen aufgeben. Es ist so ein bisschen wie eben den Paragraphen einschränken. Also etwa beim Bereich äh beim Kernbereich Schutz oder bei dem bei der, dass man eben eine unabhängige Stelle hat und so.
In den, sage ich mal, den Bereichen, die wir interessant finden im Rahmen des Logbuch Netzboth.
Sie sind nicht nicht, sondern die dürfen weiter Geld mit Beschränkungen.
Und die Beschränkung heißt im Prinzip das, was wir euch aufgegeben haben. Äh das muss müsst ihr im Prinzip auch jetzt schon sicherstellen, wenn ihr nicht wollt, dass euch das Ding.
Kann man so sagen, aber es bestimmte Juristen auch sagen ist anders, aber im Wesentlichen ist das so. Also die alte woanders, also wir hatten ja nur schon, wir bei der Vorwartsanstaltung so. War dann nicht dichtig oder beim beim Wahlcomputer, da war halt die Bundeswahlgeräteverordnung und sagen, äh Bund zwei äh,
gerittet. Doch uns meine Güte. Jedenfalls war nicht ab dem Zeitpunkt,
Bei der Vorsatzsprechung sogar noch mit löschen, wenn ihr euch erinnert, ist halt nicht immer so. Ein paar Sachen sind nicht ich. Ich weiß es aber nicht, aber nicht der Teuerner.
Es heißt ein Kampf, der, weiß ich nicht jetzt äh neun, zehn Jahre gedauert hat gegen,
Trojanisierung gegen Angriffe auf die Integrität und Vertraulichkeit unserer informationstechnischen Systeme geht mit diesem Urteil,
Nun zu Ende hatte seinen Höhepunkt zweitausendacht mit einem Grundrecht äh und hat jetzt seinen
vorläufiges Ende gefunden mit starken ähm Auflagen.
Einen sehr hohen.
Für die Online-Durchsuchung.
Es wird ein seiteneinzer Fall bleiben.
Und nicht besonders hohen für die QuellentKÜ.
Wo wir uns natürlich auch mal sehen werden, wie benutzen sie? Also da muss man, denke ich, den Behörden auf die Finger schauen und kritisch bleiben.
Da da ist natürlich die bei der Online äh bei der Quellen TKÜ haben wir natürlich, wie gesagt, den den Vorteil als Zivilbevölkerung,
dass wir ja alle Backups von unseren Systemplatten machen und lange aufbewahren und damit dann in diesem,
forensische Analysen im Rahmen der allgemeinen äh Sorgfaltspflicht äh durchführen.
Wir hätten also sollten wir nochmal sagen, dass wir wir würden Trojaner, also Staatstroana Semple auch neuerlich untersuchen.
Denke wir würden sicherlich wenn ihr dann irgendwann mal begründeten Anlass habt
dass ihr äh gesegnet wurdet von der Quellen-TKÜ und noch Backups habt, von den Systemen, dann haben wir sehr viele technisch interessierte Mitglieder in unserem Verein, äh die sich solche Sachen natürlich sehr gerne anschauen,
Ich gebe dir aber trotzdem jetzt noch kurz den Nachschub bei begründetem Anlass.
Wir haben genug äh.
Nichts gegen die äh besorgten ähm äh Computersportler, ähm die äh sich,
vorbildlich, um die Integrität äh und Vertraulichkeit ihrer Informationstechnischen Systeme sorgen. Aber es sollte dann schon irgendwie so halbwegs anders bezogen sein. Eine Analyse sollte erforderlich sein.
Und angemessen.
Und notwendig.
Gut, wir fallen schon ins Juristendeutsch.
Genau und sie muss zum Ende kommen.
Konstanze, vielen herzlichen Dank für deinen unermüdlichen Einsatz über Jahre in diesem Bereich. Ich hoffe, du.
Predigt planet auch in Zukunft.
Ich in diese in diesem.
Jetzt in Rente.
In diesem Teilbereich deines äh deines Schaffens, in diesem Teilbereich, deines Schaffens, wir müssen uns um diese Fluggastdaten äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung kümmern.
Na, siehst du mal, die digitalen Sabatisten, die haben immer was zu tun, da Lutscher, Siege, Siege.
Wer hätte gedacht, dass Gerhard Waum nochmal hier der Führer der Resistance werden würde.
Ja vom äh ja schwerter zum Flugschaden und Innenminister zu Freiheitskämpfern.
Weit ist es gekommen.
Weit ist es gekommen. Könnte schlechter laufen.
Also wir haben schon bisschen gut zu feiern. Komm, wir machen ein positives Ende jetzt. Also, ey kommende Urteil stärkt schon. Irgendwie so die Rechte von Leuten, die sich um sowas kümmern. Also wir müssen mal positiv enden.
Also du meinst die Leute beim BKH. Ich will dich doch nur ärgern, nein.
Das sieht nicht ins Boxhorn jagen. Alles super. Konstanze, vielen Dank.
Ja ich muss dich am Ende nochmal sagen, der so totale Fanboy bin und Podcast immer höre.
Das musstest du am Ende nochmal sagen, ja, das ist gut.
Das ist also das kann man nicht weglassen. Ja super. Das äh hören wir natürlich sehr gerne.
Äh eben ist mein Ende finden, Männer, das macht.
Ja, wir müssen aufhören. Ciao, ciao. Tschüss jetzt hier Feierabend. Danke.
Tschüss. Danke.